He's the content creator!
Yeah, he's the fucking content creator!
Bro, that guy was scary in Overwatch and scary in Apex!
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, he's creating content by killing us.
Yeah, that's the content!
Our content is dying to Selly.
Wait, wait, we know where he's landing!
We can just rotate away from Selly!
That's it!
Or we just go into them and just kill them.
And just feed them.
Just feed them kill points.
Let's get... oh.
Okay, do you guys know... I don't even look at where we're landing.
We're team one.
Oh, wait.
Somewhere.
We're landing somewhere.
Thank you, Yuris.
I believe in us.
Yeah.
Even more now.
Wait, which map do we have?
Solo mode, duo mode, trio mode.
All right, trio mode.
Wait, is it only Storm Point for trios?
No, I'm pretty sure we have different... there's no way it's only Storm Point.
I think we played it once.
I'm pretty sure we're rotating maps, right guys?
Oh, we have world's end.
We have world's end.
There's like, there's no way.
All right, we're landing... we are landing staging.
That is...
That is not bad.
Wouldn't call it the best landing spot.
Where are the teams next to us?
We have something.
We have...
1Tap, we have...
Oh, okay.
Tatsuki and Hesuko.
Two Japanese pros, pretty much.
Okay.
That's great to hear, man.
I feel so motivated.
1Tap and Kohaku.
A pro and a predator.
And someone else.
We have 11.
Who's 11?
Yukio...
Who the fuck?
Ok, great!
Well, then...
Okay, I think we've reached our seated level.
What's your, your, your 2019?
Do you want to go first?
Ya, maybe?
I haven't removed everything we've used on this point where it's like...
Okay...
No, those zones are fucked.
Yeah, I had like Jen on my team and like, and then it was like in the fucking open.
And like, the end zones were so bad.
I haven't played this game in a while, so I'm just gonna be in the back, just chillin'.
Yeah, you're our IGL.
If we die, it's just poor IGL-ing, right?
Yeah, it's not my fault.
It's our fault.
Yeah, I'm used to it.
Trust me, I'm used to it.
It's just poor IGL-ing, that's it.
It's not because we're washed as fuck, it's because we're in it.
No, why would that be the case, bro?
If I didn't call that, we wouldn't have been in that situation.
That's right, I believe in us.
I believe in us not being last.
I'm gonna go in with like...
Super low expectations.
As long as we're not last.
That... yeah, exactly.
Yeah, as long as like, you know, we're not...
I like that, I like that.
We don't die 20th place.
Some other poor team dies 20th place, and it's not us.
That's just fine.
We're cheering, we're cheering, we're up in a beer.
That's a win, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're not...
Yeah, that's a fucking win for me.
That is a win for me, you know?
You know what, let's make that our goal, you know?
Yeah, I just remembered, like, you know, like, when I saw, like, the landing spots announcements, I was like, ah, okay, what's Yuris doing right now?
And I see you fucking playing Overwatch, I was like, that seems right.
Yeah, I'm like, my GL in pro is super fucking locked in, let's go.
Exactly.
See, I've heard it from the previous rank number one in Apex.
Just play Overwatch.
If you wanna aim train.
That's true.
A lot of, like, the ex-Apex players are Overwatch players.
I mean, Selly was an ex-Overwatch player.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah, too.
You're the ex-Overwatch player.
I remember I used to watch you in Overwatch.
Wait, truth!
I am tired.
Hey, yeah!
Wait a second, we have a chance!
Wait!
We have our own Selly.
Except...
Let's go!
Exactly.
Except the original Selly.
I mean, Selly might be better, but like, we have our own Selly.
That guy might have been pro, you know?
I'm not too sure, I'm not well versed, but I think we could beat him.
Yeah, yeah.
We have our own Selly.
Like in a 1v3, maybe?
In a 1v3, perhaps?
Yeah, yeah.
We just gotta make sure he's alone, and then if we all shoot him at the same time, like, we can take down...
Like, he's not the pro in his team, but like, that's okay.
He's content creating.
Yeah, he's a content creator.
Like, bro, it should be easy.
He's content creating.
Yeah, yeah.
Our team is like the content team.
At this point, we're the content team.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
You guys excited?
Wait, what map are we on?
I don't even...
Oh, World's Edge.
Okay.
Alright.
How good is your zone reading, Yuris?
I don't think we should ask that.
It's pretty good.
Oh, really?
But like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're like, it's pretty shit.
I don't think we should ask that.
Yeah, no.
We're just like, what the fuck, Dino?
Dino.
What the fuck?
He's right, G.S.
Hello?
I thought we were like, just letting it go.
Like...
Not last place?
That's like a game.
Yuris, I believe in you.
But like, the zones have been pulling like, really fucking bad.
Are you like the zone reader for your team, Yuris?
Yeah, pretty much.
I pretty much just did everything on my...
I mean...
The latest ALGS team.
Oh shit.
You did everything?
Yeah, the IGLing, the entry, the zone read.
The mental care?
How's your mental?
Yeah, the mental care was like half of ALGS and then after that half of it's like, I was broken.
I needed someone else to do the mental care.
Yeah, that's why you got... after pro league you went to Overwatch.
The best game for mental...
And guess what?
That did not help.
Yeah, I was gonna say Overwatch is not known for mental care.
Just saying.
It's like if you play it too much you either become very immune to toxicity or you become the toxicity.
Oh yeah, that's so true.
That's a good way to put it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cause I know that people will be like, yeah I came from Overwatch.
And you're like, oh, I get it man.
Should I be this dude's friend?
That's so true.
Oh my god, that's so true.
It's like which part of Overwatch?
The really bad side or the good one?
Which Overwatch player are you?
Which Overwatch... which type of Overwatch player are you?
At least you didn't come from NA Valorant.
I don't know.
I don't know if like JP Valorant is any better but like NA Valorant is a whole new side of toxicity.
Um...
I remember playing in beta in NA.
That was funny.
It's kinda a thing.
It's like you just breathe and they start like roasting you.
Oh, true, true.
My first day on NA Valorant I got called a gamer word and I was like, alright, I'm just gonna mute everything.
I'm just kidding.
Why so fast?
I literally... I just like literally said one word and I was like, well, time to mute everybody.
Goodbye.
Goodbye NA Valorant.
Yeah, you see, actually I've been playing a lot of Japanese or Japan servers in Valorant and it's not... not like... it's not that bad to be honest.
It's just no one... no one is like... it's rare to like play with a, you know, a toxic loud game.
But they have their own way of like trolling.
They have their own way of being toxic.
Like how so?
They're just passive aggressive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They talk at like the last second of the game.
Like when you already lost.
Like when you leave the lobby.
With the sound like, you suck.
Fuck you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
They just hold it in until the last minute.
They're like, I'm never gonna see you anyway.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
That's how they do it here in Japan.
I mean, I mean that's better.
That's better than like getting yelled at in the beginning.
That's true.
Just like, you know, cause like in Valorant you can't leave.
You can't leave until like somebody surrenders or like, or like you have to play the full game of someone yelling at you.
At least they save it till the end, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
That's true.
That is true.
Alright, alright.
Do you guys know what team?
Okay, so we're playing Bloodhound, Bangalore, and Wadian?
And Valkyrie.
Do you play Bloodhound, Doki?
Okay, I can play... wait, okay, but I'm not on controller.
But like no one in Asia is really on controller.
So...
It's not like NA.
Oh no, there's actually a lot.
There's actually a lot more than you think.
I think it's more... everyone in Korea is more like...
Everyone in Korea doesn't play controller.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but I think like in NA it's almost like... it's every team has like a ruler player.
Oh, yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, so like, you know, NA tournaments are so scary.
I'll be like, hey, I'm the MNK player here.
Hello.
Please be nice.
Then I already have the disadvantage.
Disadvantage.
Sorry, my team is... sorry for being a... sorry for being a nerf for your team.
I have the wrong input.
You can usually play.
I can play.
Do you go by Doki or like...
Doki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, alright.
I can't... I just not Valk.
I can do either Blood or... Blood or Bang.
Blood or Bang.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I play... I play Bang and Nen.
Okay, I do Blood.
Just yell at me.
Just micromanage me for scans.
Just watch a little clip, you know, like a little VOD review.
A little VOD?
We're having a VOD review?
We're gonna do VOD review?
Right before a tournament, you know.
That's when you should VOD review probably.
What VOD?
Let's see.
DSG is playing Bloodhound Caustic Wraith.
Alright, that's interesting.
That's already interesting.
That's already something different.
Okay, but DSG is like Metacrashers.
Caustic seems to be the meta.
Yeah, I see about Caustic now because of like how f*** the zones are.
So they have to like have Caustic to zone out things.
Oh...
The roller player is usually on the Bloodhound, but like since we don't have a roller player...
I've never held a controller in my life, man.
Like actually.
I bought a $500 controller and I used it like... and I only used it for not Apex.
You know those Battle Beaver controllers that every f***ing Apex pro advertises?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I used it like one time for Apex and then every other time it's just for other games that need controller.
I can't.
I don't know how to do it.
It's so difficult.
I can't either, bro.
I get so mad when I'm using controller.
Like why the f*** am I so bad?
It's like I touch a controller and it's like...
Alright, I'm going back to MBK.
GG's.
It's so hard.
I don't...
But then like...
But then when it hits, when that aim assist hits though, oh my god.
And I'm like...
I can't go back!
Yeah, when it hits it...
When it hits it hits.
Yeah, when it hits it hits.
Like one out of ten fights you miss everything or...
Like nine out of ten fights you miss everything in that one fight.
You just one clip every time.
Yeah, and then you're like, oh controller's OP!
What the f*** is this bullshit?
And that was a one out of ten.
Aim assist is broken!
From what I've observed, we should play...
We should play Caustic.
Caustic?
Okay.
Not it.
Yeah.
I don't know what that is.
I don't...
I don't even think I have him unlocked, man.
Wait, you don't have Caustic...
Wait, what?
How do you not have Caustic unlocked?
That's just default, bro.
Ain't nothing I can do.
I think I have the different DLC, man.
Bro, I have a million ledger tokens.
How do you not have Caustic unlocked?
I don't think I got him, bro.
Oh my god.
Pookie, leave the lobby and unlock it right now.
It would be funny if you leave and they actually stop.
Oh, wait, you actually left.
Wait, where did you go?
I need to join the lobby.
I was just shooting them bots.
Oh, we were waiting.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Just so you know.
You were definitely the last person.
Yeah, yeah.
Heroes come late, you know?
No, I'm sorry.
It's okay.
Some people...
Does that one guy have that wheel so that he loaded in last?
No, I'm sorry.
Yeah, technically.
We were like...
Oh my god.
We literally started because you joined.
I'm so sorry.
Oh shit.
I was literally just tap scraping around a bot.
To find this.
All right, wait.
I'll play Bang.
You can play Bloodhound, Dohki.
Okay.
And Tayo, you can play...
You can play...
Okay.
What am I playing?
You can play Valk.
I can play anything.
We'll do that.
Give me a character name.
We just did.
We literally said Valk.
Just give me a character name.
We did.
We told you to play Valk.
Valk.
I wanna play Valk.
It's like, play Valk.
Give me anything.
I can play anything.
Valk.
Anything.
But caustic.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why aren't we starting?
Someone's restarting.
Look, it wasn't you.
See, I wasn't the last person.
See, it wouldn't have mattered.
I saw this coming.
Even if you joined early.
It's never your fault.
Just remember that.
As a competitive player, it's never your fault.
And always somebody else's fault.
Yeah, it's never my fault.
I'm sorry if we lose today, but it's not my fault.
Yeah, sorry.
It was ping.
Bad RGL.
Bad RNG.
Battle Royale.
RNG.
No, there's this guy called fucking all wingman please.
This dude is locked in.
Really?
This guy is supposed to be fucking punching the entire game.
He's gonna use the P2020, bro.
Oh my god.
You're the competitor, bro.
You probably have to be fighting that guy for your wingman.
Yeah, I'm sorry, but...
You see a wingman package and you know he's there.
He's gonna be across the map heading for it.
It's gonna be me, Selly, and this guy.
All fucking carefree.
Yeah, yeah.
There's always like three teams fighting for fucking packs.
Wait, how is team one fair?
What the fuck?
We're team one.
I'm hyping us up.
I'm hyping us up, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, team one.
Team one?
What the fuck is wrong with team one?
Don't look at my badges.
But like what the fuck is wrong with team one?
So technically we didn't count.
This starts from team two.
Team one.
Team two?
Like goddamn.
What the fuck?
Okay, team two is actually pretty scary though.
I'm pretty sure Tokotoa is also really good.
Yeah, Toa is pretty good.
Holy shit.
I remember always meeting her in these...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, did you just say performance?
This is a fun tournament.
I'm here dead serious.
You're so... yeah, yeah.
You're so... when was the last time you streamed Apex, Tayo?
How serious are you?
Like two hours ago.
Like, okay, before today.
Before today.
Like a year ago.
Wait, I'm gonna look up your Twitch bots right now.
What do you mean, like a year ago?
A year ago.
My aim is pretty on point.
You're right, you're right.
Overwatch aim travels...
You were literally streaming Overwatch yesterday.
Bro, I'm looking at your bots.
You have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Bro, how long does the Overwatch go?
Every day.
I'm ready.
I'm watching.
Bro, 24 days ago you were on Apex.
24 days ago you were on Apex.
Oh yeah, no, for the tournament.
For what tournament?
The one where Uri's got like 30 kills.
Oh shit.
Oh yeah, that tournament.
Okay, redo it.
Replicate that.
That was a hard warm up for this tournament.
Yeah, I got you.
We need you to do that again.
Yeah, I was speaking Japanese that time.
Maybe we can do it better.
You know, since I'm on English mode now.
Oh, you're right.
Just think you're... Just think you're...
I think you're in Pro League again.
If we lose, blame it on the IGL.
Exactly.
Don't worry, you don't need to tell me that.
I was going to anyway.
Yeah, that was a shit.
I don't know what you're on about, but...
Don't worry, I'm so ahead of you.
I was ready to blame you if we lose.
Wait, wait, are you in...
Uri's, are you in...
Are you in Japan now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm in Japan now.
So you have the JP ping too.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
Oh yeah, you have like 120, 30, 40, 50, 60, right?
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
He was just like, what?
Wait, no, no, he's asking... Wait, are you asking me?
No, no, no, Doki, Doki.
Oh no, I'm on...
Oh, I thought you were asking Uri's.
No, I'm on a fucking a hundred and...
a hundred and twenty ping.
Yeah, I get this... I get the same amount of ping to Japan to East Coast.
That's how fucked... that's how fucked it is.
Are the servers that bad?
Like, West to East, and oh, it's like 60, like 50 ping.
Yeah, no, it's so true!
I was like, what the fuck?
I literally get like, almost the same ping from East to Tokyo.
It's actually crazy.
So I'm like, it's fine.
It's fine.
The house is burning down, but it's fine.
I might have to...
It's actually crazy.
I have never played a tournament in Apex from NA with less than a hundred ping.
I've always had a hundred ping in tournaments.
Even in NA servers.
How?
I know, bro.
Bro, it's just West Coast debuff.
It's just...
We actually nerfed by default.
There's like nobody ever puts servers in West Coast.
It's always in East Coast.
It's always, yeah.
It's literally West Coast debuff.
Or just West Coast Canadians debuff.
Oh, we're starting.
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah, okay.
Bloodhound.
I'm so locked in.
Wait, where are we landing here?
Staging.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's like a left of harvest.
Oh, 2k?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, dude.
Let's go.
Where the fuck is Bloodhound?
Alright.
Oh, there you go.
Valkyrie, Valkyrie, Valkyrie.
Alright.
Bloodhound.
What do I upgrade?
Oh, wait, shit.
You're right.
What do I upgrade?
Wait, guys.
I can't ICL that far.
Hold on.
You supposed to put micro and macro us.
Holy shit.
The one... Okay.
Tayo, you upgrade the one that lets you fly like higher.
And you just go...
Doki, you upgrade the one for... the scan lasts longer and...
What the fuck?
What else?
Wait, there's Raven?
There's the one on the left, I think.
Oh, wait.
Odin's glare?
Or the Raven?
Yeah, something like that.
I think you loot Mirage, Doki, so we can scan the beacon.
Me?
Okay.
Wait, is there anybody else?
No one else is in Mirage, right?
I'm not gonna get fucking run up on, right?
Nah, no one goes Mirage.
Yeah.
Alright.
If they do, I'll get them banned from Biggest Scars.
It's my team's stream.
You'll get them banned next year.
Yeah, I'll get them fucking banned.
But who's next to us, by the way?
We're gonna land right here.
Uh, right there... I forgot.
Alright.
It doesn't matter.
We're better.
Alright, it's okay.
You guys will pick up my banner, right?
If I die...
We'll be fine.
Yeah, we will.
We definitely will.
Yeah, yeah.
We don't have any crafting legends, by the way.
Just so you guys remember.
So you have to pick me up.
Alright.
If you guys see a...
Actually, no.
You guys are so far.
I want not travel back to all of you.
Should I get a repeater?
I have a repeater.
Repeater's still busted, right?
There's a purple stock here.
Yeah.
I heard it's alright.
I heard Havoc is pretty fucking busted.
Havoc's really good.
I'm gonna grab that.
I'm just gonna wait for a hemlock or some shit.
Gonna start the party.
Ooh.
Party started!
Let's see.
It's looking like a little eastern zone.
Somewhere...
Oh.
Dude, I got my hammer from Mozambique.
That's it.
We're so locked in.
Nice.
Wait, that's actually low-key strong.
I'm not even joking.
Yeah, if you get a...
If you have a... What do you call this?
A digi threat?
You can fucking like... Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Cause it's on pistol zone now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
No, there you go.
I found a Havoc.
Alright.
Havoc on 120 ping.
Let's go.
Let me have time to charge it up.
There's a gold heavy mag right here.
Landslides already leaving.
Bro, what?
Okay.
They're... Wait.
I'm gonna...
I guess...
I'm gonna go up.
I have three bats if anyone needs any.
Be careful.
Be careful of this team flying Taya.
They're flying towards... Yeah, yeah.
I'm running.
Oh, we have a point here.
I didn't realize.
I have like...
I have okay guns.
Do you need a heavy mag and stuff?
No, I'm using a bolt right now.
There's a flatline here.
Alright.
I'm gonna go grab the harvester.
Yeah.
And then I'll scan.
So we know where people are going.
Yup, yup.
It's okay.
I have no clue what you just said.
I agree.
I feel so confident.
There's no harvester.
Alright, I'm gonna go scan.
So we know where people are going.
I'm gonna get this bin here.
Yeah, we definitely need blue armor.
Oh, everybody's going here.
Yeah.
Can we have a good...
Can we have a good rotate here?
A good little rotate.
Start going back to staging.
Oh, staging?
Okay.
I got a hammer point for you.
Or a digi threat for you there.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I think everybody is already setting up in harvester area.
Yeah, they're in harvester.
I think we keep staging here.
And like fight.
And just like slow rotate in.
Oh, hey, there's a...
There's a bug.
I have a faster reaction time.
Thank you.
Who gets the helmet?
I get it.
I get it for now.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Oh, I've been right fighting already.
I hope they kill them off so not...
I can't see who...
I can't teabag.
Oh, you can't teabag?
It's okay.
The thing is you always teabag.
You always teabag.
It doesn't matter who.
It's equality.
Alright, we'll chill right here.
Alright.
I feel so safe with my blue armor.
The team underneath us here isn't like an OP team, you know?
Oh, yeah.
We can handle everyone.
Yeah, yeah.
We can definitely handle everybody.
I 100% agree.
Yeah.
We can craft bats here too.
I have four bats if anyone needs more.
I need a sculpt.
They're flying towards...
Oh, a tree.
Okay.
A tree?
That's interesting.
Wasn't the bot side heavily...
There's so many people, right?
Left side isn't looted.
We want to loot the left.
I'm going to scan this crow.
There's people too.
Should I get the ultimate accelerator?
You should, yeah.
Ultimate.
Ultimate accelerator is always good.
Do you need this?
No.
I have 2x.
Yeah, I like the...
...fucking stock scope.
There's a blue heavy here.
Where is another scan?
Oh, there's another...
The next scan we have is harvester.
The 30-30.
You know, fuck it.
I'm going to take the 30-30 too.
Come on, Nemesis Mozambique.
See where the zone is pulling.
Looks like a...
...lava siphon zone.
Where all those guys were flying.
Lava siphon?
I think so.
There was like 2 teams already stationed at lava.
Yeah.
I guess finding a stock.
Alright.
Actually, I'm going to craft a bat too.
I hope I don't get killed.
Dude, I'm so scared.
I'm just like...
...near Yuris.
He's my daddy.
I'm just too scared.
Whoa!
Wait, stop.
To the right.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can't get to you guys yet.
I'm going to walk up.
Oh yeah, we have a really good spot.
I think we fight this.
I'm heading off to you guys.
Posture up.
I cracked the bloodhound.
I'm moving up left.
Moving up left and taking space.
Don't worry.
I'm 5 seconds away.
Inside the ship.
I'm here.
I don't have an angle.
I got an angle.
Cracked!
Nice, nice.
I have a good crosshair.
I'm bank-holding them too.
Wait, where did they go?
Are they still inside?
They're still inside.
They're running.
I'm good on me.
They took the zip.
I'm taking space.
Okay.
I'm looking to my right just in case a team walks up.
They're inside.
As long as we keep height, that's fine.
We're going to play for this side right here.
See my ping?
We're going to play for that height over there.
On the east side.
We just keep him on the low ground.
Oh my god, guys!
We're not last!
Somebody die!
We're done!
We're so fucking good.
We're so good at this game.
I'm going to scan thermal too.
I'm going to look.
Keep looking at the team and staging.
I'm going to look behind us.
I'll look at them.
I don't even see them inside.
Did they rotate out?
No, no.
They're on this side.
They're on the door.
I see them.
There's a team playing here on this side.
They're rotating out.
They're rotating now.
They smoked out.
They're going up to the zip.
I'm just...
Oh, they're getting shot at!
I have a caustic.
You were shooting them.
I was like, whoa!
They're getting shot at!
It's your reason!
They are getting shot at.
On the roof.
If there's more cells, let me know.
Right here.
They should...
They're not getting shot behind.
We can't really commit to this fight because there's a team behind this.
Oh, they're committing.
Okay.
Let them waste their bloodhound ult.
Just don't take too much damage.
Right there.
They're getting shot.
This time they are getting shot at.
Yep, yep.
Oh, god.
No ammo.
There's a team zipping to the village.
Oh, shit.
God rotate.
God damn.
Look at the fucking zip onto it.
Yeah, they just fucking...
I have a redeploy.
We have two redeploys, so we need it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't want to use my...
I don't want to use my bullets.
I have four bats if anyone needs an extra bat.
We just chill.
We'll see how this zone pulls.
We don't have to do anything crazy.
We can even go in the tunnel if we have to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have the redeploy too.
We need to use it.
Keep scanning this team.
Yeah, I can.
I'll scan it now.
Yep.
Oh, my gosh.
They're bunkered up.
Yeah, they're heavily bunkered up.
They're like free shots anyway.
Yeah, they're like free shots anyway.
This guy right here.
If they push up here, I'm gonna smoke this and we're gonna run into the tunnel so we have better angles.
Oh, yeah.
You can even play up there.
I feel so safe.
They're running?
They're at the back door.
I'm scanning?
Oh, yeah.
They smoked back.
They're still in the house.
Oh, yeah.
We have a decent...
Wait.
I'm gonna check.
I'm gonna go to the tunnel right now.
I'm gonna check our rotate.
There's a team on height here.
Okay.
If we can somehow get to this fucking building.
These buildings here.
Wait, can we make it over here?
Yeah, we...
We buckled.
Right here?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe in your flying.
We're gonna go into the buildings here.
Go through here.
Go behind this.
Oh my god.
We're fucking flying.
Get into the buildings here.
Let's chill here for now.
This one?
Yeah, this one.
We have both these buildings.
I'm gonna watch behind.
No one should be in these buildings.
Just this team on the height.
I'm gonna go to the big one building.
Yeah, I'm watching our back.
Holy shit, that Valk.
That was clutch.
That was fucking clutch there.
Oh my god, look at you.
Look at your IGL go.
Alright, we're good.
We're good till next zone.
I'm acting surprised you're easy to do.
You don't believe in your Valk player?
Shit, okay, I'm good.
I'm okay.
Oh shit.
It's the people that were trying to sandwich us, right?
I knew it.
I'm sure he's telling.
I'm not fucking going under that roof anymore.
That was scary.
On this next zone close, no one should technically come from behind.
Okay, I'm just gonna go and stay inside for now.
They're still there.
Let's check if there's a...
If they start fighting there, we definitely push that.
There's a guy right there.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Fuck you.
Looking?
You lost the fucking Valkyrie fight.
The rockin' duel.
For the youth, like, hit yourself.
No, no.
I would never.
Alright, here we go.
I don't see them.
Are they up this?
Yeah, yeah, that's...
Both of our teammates are like...
watching the other side.
If I have a 3x...
I'm pretty sure... yeah, I was gonna say, it's definitely gonna pull here.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
We have our... you're gonna have a Valk ult, right?
Their Valk ult Valk?
Oh yeah, let me just charge my thing.
I forgot I had it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They might be pushing us.
Oh yeah, they are, they are.
Yeah, I scan, I scan, I scan.
Alright, I'm Valk ulting, I'm Valk ulting.
We play up, we play up, we play up.
I'm inside,
first floor.
Oh, at me?
I'm burning one, I'm burning one.
I'm burning one.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
I'm buffing the back, I'm buffing the back.
Oh, fuck.
There's three right here.
Oh, they're all flashed.
I believe in you, Ryze.
He's flash, he's flash, he's flash.
He might be my bat though.
He was here last time, but I don't know where he is now.
I got sked here.
I'm ping, I'm ping, I'm ping.
He's arcing.
I'm ulting right side.
He's rezzing.
They're rezzing, they're rezzing, they're rezzing.
He's outside, he's outside.
He's reloading, he's right here.
I'm ping, I'm ping.
He's peeking.
He's going my side, he's on me.
He's over here, he's over here.
I'm better, I'm better.
It's okay, guys.
He knew it was gonna happen.
Zone?
We're gonna reset, we're gonna back ult instantly.
Just pop a medkit, Kyle.
I'm popping a Phoenix.
This is scary.
We're on the slow side.
Go up the ramp.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm fucking running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I don't even have time to heal.
Pop a medkit, pop a medkit, pop a medkit, pop a medkit, pop a medkit.
Pop a medkit and we're gonna bot lane.
Right here?
Or up the slope?
Keep going up, keep going up.
Yeah, keep going up.
Wait, I think we just...
Tell me one.
Ready?
I think you have to leave me to die.
You have to leave me to die.
Just leave me to die.
Just run, just run, just run.
Leave me to die.
I believe.
I'm flying.
Can I make this?
I made it.
You guys got this?
I made it too.
How's your 14 squad still?
Wait, how am I alive?
Are you good?
You good?
Come to me, come to me.
I hope I am.
There's still 13 squads?
Are you kidding me?
No!
No.
Are they flicking me?
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
They're like way in the back.
I think I can go to you actually.
Are they fighting?
No, no, no, no.
They're just like in the fucking Narnia.
In the fucking Narnia.
They just...
No way!
They're random sniper men!
Top 10!
Go on, just lift the top 10!
I'm never fucking forgiving this guy.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Bro!
My bad.
I believe in you.
Top 10.
Oh, okay.
I believe in you a little less now.
Wait, he has av meds!
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Tayo has av meds.
Two med kits, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Get the juice.
There's no way.
Who the fuck's this guy?
Oh, that's not a guy.
That's a team.
That's his teammate!
11-11!
We're almost top 10.
Okay, top 10.
We need those points.
We have kill points too!
Oh shit.
Plus bandages.
Oh, oh, oh.
He won't shoot you.
Yeah, he won't shoot you.
He's too scared.
There's no way he tries to shoot you.
You're so...
Oh my god.
No!
We're so close to top 10!
We're really, really close.
Oh my god.
So close, man.
Why did the team push us?
They have a free rotate.
They needed the kill points.
At least we got three kill points, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what?
We got three kill points.
That secure us not last.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That should secure us not last.
Exactly.
Unless we get last place the next five games.
But that's...
That'll never happen.
At least we're not last here.
Bro, that team that got Harvester...
Fucking so free.
Oh yeah, true.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
I can't believe we got pushed there.
Yeah, I was like, Scan, I was like, wait a minute.
I thought they were just gonna kill.
I was like, alright.
They know we have Balth, you know?
We're gonna like...
Yeah, they were gonna be like, is that free rotate?
Nothing's for free.
Push, push.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
We have to earn the rotation.
That would have to be like the fucking scariest rotate.
I still count back.
I still believe there was still like 14 squads.
When I died.
Nah, yeah, that was crazy.
That was so scary.
This dude's just rising in the middle of the fucking war zone.
Yeah, waiting to climb up.
Oh my god, whoever's inside is so lucky.
Which team is this?
Yeah, it is.
What team am I spectating?
I'm expecting a Bang, Caustic, Bloodhound team.
Yeah, they're on top, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not gonna lie though, that fight was a good fight.
It was, yeah.
I literally did zero damage.
I walked in behind them.
I thought I could get a flank.
And there was just three people just looking at me.
I was like, oh, this is good knowing you guys.
I was gonna say, I cracked three people.
And I was like, I was like so scared.
I was like, wait.
You said you cracked them, so I was like, there's no way they're gonna be looking at me.
There's no way they'll see you, you know?
There's no way.
They were just all looking at me.
It's okay, that's why we have your ease here.
I had my Mozambique out and everything.
Oh, the Mozambique.
Wait, you didn't get to shoot your Mozambique?
No, I shot it once and...
No.
Bro, you have 60!
I'm sad.
This team is definitely winning, right?
Yeah, yeah, high ground.
I mean, I don't know, cause high ground is not in the...
It's not in the...
The ringside.
So they can shoot them down.
I... you know...
If you didn't say that, I would not have known.
And I would not have seen your damage.
Is that GP?
Yeah, I did like 10.
How much damage did I do?
You did 60.
That's like from the start, where I was like peppering them.
What is 60 damage, bro?
What happened?
Bro...
I'm warming up, and my fucking rookie 30 damage.
Why isn't it fucking applying here?
I don't understand.
I don't understand why it's...
That's a sick ass fucking bloodhound scan.
Yeah bro, that's sick.
That skin's sick.
Oh my god, it's okay.
We're the content creators.
Guess who won, guys.
Is it Celia's team?
Or is it Celia's team?
At least you can't see the damage.
Oh yeah, it's...
Wait, what's that?
Tiki.
Tiki's so scary.
Yeah, he's playing with Pinotak.
Three kills, not bad.
We got three kills.
Yeah, not last.
Yeah, exactly.
That's all we wanted.
Just by looking at the leaderboard, I'm thinking we're like a little 16th, 13th, 14th type shit.
Nah, I'm going top 10, bro.
I'm going top 10.
Not last.
It's all I want.
As long as I'm not last.
Because if you're not first...
If you're not first, placements don't matter.
Except for last.
The only positions that matter is first, last, and everything in between is the same.
Yeah, everything in between is just you participated.
You were there.
That's true.
Everybody remembers the 5th place team or the 6th place or the 3rd place team.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
Everybody remembers the first and the last.
I'm just picking up a fucking repeater.
I can't use anything else.
Just don't pick up the Mozamm.
Mozamm's cursed.
We know now.
I'm just so sad.
I could have picked up a Mastiff, but I'm like, no.
This Mozamm is my life.
You're just like, you know what?
Mozamm's the way to go.
And you're like, you know what?
You're right.
Listen, listen, listen.
Guess what?
It was the IGL's fault.
Oh yeah!
It was!
Yuris, you told me to get the fucking Mozamm.
Exactly.
That's not my bad.
That was you.
You told him.
He had a chance to actually do damage.
I'm sad.
Alright, now all you have to do is do the opposite of what Yuris tells you to do.
That's true.
And then you'll have more damage.
Alright, where are we landing on Stormpoint?
Are we playing the same comp?
Uh, same comp, yeah.
Um, actually, yeah, yeah.
I like our bot, bro.
If we just didn't get, you know, cocked by the fucking people running at us.
You got cocked by Lee.
Who were they?
It was Team Satsuki.
Team 15.
Who was Team 15?
It was Tappy.
It was fucking Tappy!
Team 14.
Oh, okay, Team 14.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Yeah, they have Hisshiko.
That's understandable.
Understandable.
They have Satsuki.
That's understandable.
Oh!
What's that supposed to be?
He's the controller brain, bro.
Satsuki.
Oh, he's just running down, guys?
Just running down at the aim assist.
It's alright.
It'll lock in for us.
They're like, that team, they saw us shoot them and they're like, that team's mouse and keyboard.
We got this.
Look at that guy with the mosem beam.
Look at that guy.
60 damage.
Look at that.
They saw the mosem beam and pushed him.
They saw the mosem.
Look at this dude.
He has the mosem.
Oh.
He just ran at them.
I mean, it worked.
They killed me.
Yeah, they took you down so fucking fast.
Dude, that was so...
Bro, they ignored me and killed you first even though I was right in front of them.
That was actually crazy.
No, they knew the mosem was the threat.
They knew the mosem was going to threaten them.
Yeah, exactly.
They knew it had a hammer point on it.
They were like, oh no.
Gotta take him down.
It's okay.
They're like, oh no.
He's M and K.
We got this.
Alright.
I just need him.
Where are we landing?
Oh yeah.
We need to look at where we're landing.
Left of lightning rod.
They call that place.
Zoo station.
Zoo station?
Who's around us?
Oh my god, where is it?
Vodka steam.
Oh yeah, nice.
We can kill them.
Is that our girl?
Final words.
We can kill them.
20 plays.
Let's see.
Where the fuck is the...
Where is the map?
I just see storm...
Oh, there's storm point.
Wait, they're not near us.
I don't even see 18.
16, 13, 15.
We have 16, 13, and 15 left.
They're just walking around us.
We have Tappy.
We have Saku.
And we have...
I always don't know how to pronounce 16.
How do you pronounce 16's name?
F-chan.
F-chan?
Like C-H-A-N.
Ah.
We're in.
Guys, we're top 10!
We're top 10?
We're in!
The three kills.
Our three kills put us up there.
Wait.
Wait, where are you getting this info?
Someone in my chat.
Oh, okay.
The source is chat.
Oh shit, wait.
I'm not sure about that.
How reliable is your chat?
My chat doesn't troll me when it comes to placements.
Don't worry.
Don't troll me.
Alright, we're top 10.
Let's go.
We can do this, I believe.
My goal of this next game is to get more than 60 damage.
Oh, yeah.
That would be fun, right?
Aim low, you know?
So you'll always be surprised.
You'll always be surprised.
I can't wait for the solos and we can watch your ease.
Yeah, we're just shit-talking.
Yeah, we...
Okay, guys, let's not...
It's gonna be like, comms, comms, and then we're just having a conversation.
Yo, me and Doki's duos is gonna go to shit.
Oh, we're so fucked.
I'm sorry.
It's my fault.
I believe in you guys.
Can you like, watch us?
You can spectate us, right?
Or like, we have to screen share for you.
Cause I assume like, Uri's can't fucking spectate or he'll like, ghost for us.
I would never do that.
Cause like, it's supposed to be like, your pro player is supposed to coach you.
Can we land here?
Or nah?
Yeah, you just hear me like, whispering like, Yo, there's a team in front of you.
Yo, yo, there's a team in front of you.
The end zone is like, over there.
I can see everything.
Godspot's open.
Yeah, godspot, nobody's there.
Nobody's there.
Yeah, cause I was like, cause it says like, your coach is supposed to coach, like your pro player is supposed to coach you.
And I'm like, how?
Did we screen share?
Oh, really?
Oh fuck.
I'm about to have like, 10 tabs here, bro.
Yeah.
Just, you know, just don't...
Trust me when I say land there.
You probably can't know, but I know.
He's like, hey, you know that area over there?
You should totally land there.
You know, there's...
My gut's telling me that fucking building is open.
Your gut is telling you.
Yeah, my gut is like, my second monitor.
I have a hemlock with a gold...
or purple...
What the heck?
Oh my god.
It's gonna give us this landing spot.
It just has nothing.
Anyone need this shit?
Wait, there's so many Havocs.
I have a...
Yeah, I want the Havoc.
I have a carbine...
Carbine alternator?
I need a fucking different second gun.
Um...
Okay.
Yeah, I don't have a second gun.
I haven't... I trapped an alternator, if anyone wants it.
Oh, there's an R9.
Isn't that dog?
Yeah, but...
Dude, there's a Mozambique.
Yeah.
Don't pick up the Mozambique!
Or you're gonna get like 40 damage.
I picked it up.
Oh no.
Definitely gonna get 40 damage now.
Did anyone loot the backside yet?
Uh...
That side?
No, not all the way down now.
Oh, they did.
Okay, we're not that far from zone.
Thank god.
Um... let's see.
Yeah, I think we're gonna go for this can.
Get that little... um...
Harvester.
Go back to Zeus.
Get this little...
We need purple so bad.
Yeah...
Wait, they actually... I think they had purple when we fought them.
I don't remember.
Yeah, they did.
That team had purple.
Yeah, they were gaming.
I'm running... Carbine Prowler.
I should be good.
With my loot.
Unlock Mozambique.
You like the Prowler?
Yeah, Prowler's great.
Respect.
What the heck?
No, I respect that actually.
That is fucking great, man.
I just need to hit one shot...
one beat burst and we're fine.
That's like almost a crack.
Alright.
Oh, I'll scan that.
I replay for this beacon scan and we're gonna go.
They haven't looted it yet.
If you see a better shotgun than a fucking Lozan...
There you go.
Oh!
Got you bro, I got you.
I'm never letting you be on the...
Fucking Lozan.
And before he does less damage.
Zero.
Where the fuck is the...
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where is this?
I'm scanning.
Yup.
We're there.
Recovering.
Oh, that's a gold mask.
Oh, everybody's heading here.
I think that's the...
Here or Cito?
Is that a pylon or Cito?
Yeah, it looks like a pylon.
Looks like a pylon zone.
Oh, we are gonna get purple, guys.
Oh, I'm gonna grab the harvester.
The Evo.
Cause it's right next to me.
We got some attachments here.
Should be fine.
Oh my god, everybody's there already.
These guys...
I don't see the doggies.
I forgot like, uh, JP servers, everybody just rotates.
We're gonna go up here after.
Yeah.
Actually we should go up now.
It's kind of... zones can't kill me.
I'm gonna take this cannon.
Take the cannon here.
Let's go up here.
We're gonna play for this Evo harvester over there.
And scan the beacon again.
Look at this, guys.
IGL.
Such great IGL.
Don't worry.
Thank you, thank you.
If we do like, NA IGL, they won't expect it.
Cause they're so used to JP strats.
Exactly.
We're the NA strats here.
What the fuck is this team?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's the NA team.
It's the NA team.
What's this team still doing outside of zone?
English speaking team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, the NA team is still out of zone.
Always out of zone.
Never in.
There's zone healing.
We're not getting routed here, right, Thio?
That's not a thing that ever happens.
Yeah, no way.
Even though you guys have...
Oh, we have blue armor!
Nice!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're up, bro.
We're up in the world.
Are you doing the spiders?
We should do spiders, right?
We should do the spiders and then we're gonna rotate there as well.
Alright.
We're almost here.
I'm just running around.
I don't know this map.
Or the building.
Alright, I'll go scan.
There's a nemesis here in front of me.
If anybody wants that.
I'm good.
I'm Baptiste.
Alright.
Scanning?
Oh yes, give me all the extensions.
Oh, there is definitely.
There's a...
Digi here.
There's a team there.
I can't put it on my mask.
I'm good.
Oh my god.
There's like a team here.
There's a full team here.
It's definitely a pylon zone.
Looking like a pylon zone, guys.
Definitely does, yeah.
Team's going for this.
Rotating up.
I think we should rotate towards...
Stormcatcher.
I need a bat.
I don't even want...
There's a...
I have two bats now.
I have four.
I have two.
I'm going to go slow.
I'm going to check the lid.
Oh, another bat there.
I'm going to go take it.
Yeah, you can get it.
Grab it.
There you go.
Let us go.
Oh, dude.
If I had my fucking...
...Mozan, I would have got that.
No.
Resist the Mozans temptation.
Resist it.
I think...
I need like a fucking...
...Heavy Mag.
A Prowler.
For a Prowler.
Ready?
I'm ready, yeah.
Heavy Mag or the Prowler?
I need a Heavy Mag.
Weeeeee.
Alright, we take the zip...
...towards Stormcatcher too.
Okay.
Did you hear like Punch Boosting is sort of back?
Because of a bug?
Oh, really?
That's why I'm flying.
I don't know if they like reverted, but like...
...apparently Punch Boosting was back for a bit.
Wait, I think it is.
I think they used Reboot.
It feels like it.
Yeah, I fell a little faster there.
It's Placebo.
Yeah, it's Placebo.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
I think it is Placebo.
Are we taking the jumpy?
Wait, scan our right?
Scanning.
Okay.
We're going to the right side real quick.
We're playing for this Harvest.
I heard someone.
Maybe they're below us.
Ohhhhh.
Do we have a bird?
A little birdie?
Uh, nope.
We're going to play for this beacon scan.
On low ground.
Oh yeah, there's a team right there.
I don't see it.
We should scan it right now.
They zipped up on this height.
Let's see.
Do I do a tactical...
...coldown or taste of blood?
Gain 25 HP or...
...reduce tactical cooldown?
Tactical cooldown.
I think no one's here.
Scan the beacon.
I'm going to take space here.
Alright.
Oh, punch boosting back, baby.
It is?
Oh, okay.
Bro, I got so happy for no reason.
It feels faster though.
It does feel faster.
Yeah.
Okay.
Scanning?
No one should be in this compound.
I think.
I think they left.
Yeah, there's here, here, here.
No one's in pylon.
Wait.
Let's go.
We're going to ult from this cannon right here.
We're going to take this side of the building.
Woah.
That's so scary.
Yeah, that is scary.
That is so scary.
I know.
Trust me.
It's okay.
I trust IGL.
And we're going to get in this thing.
I trust you with my life.
I'm sweating right now.
I'm actually scared.
It all comes down to this fucking Valko.
We're here.
Just ping, ping, okay?
Ready?
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah.
I will.
Yep.
Just go over this hill for now.
Alright, the first step.
Tired to go over this hill.
Wait.
Did someone just take it?
No, no.
We're good.
Wait.
I think they're taking it.
Ping, ping, ping.
There's one in front of us.
In front of us.
Where?
On me.
Land on me.
Yeah, I landed.
I landed.
Oh, Talos.
Talos.
Well, you pinged the wrong...
Okay.
I have gold.
Nice.
Get inside right away.
I don't have a scan.
I already used it.
Oh, I'm so fucked.
Payne, that side.
Payne, that side for now.
No.
I can shield.
Shielding.
Oh, yep.
I don't know, man.
That...
I have my...
Bad timing.
Someone flew as soon as we flew.
Yeah.
It's okay.
We're not last.
You're east.
The rat.
Let's go.
Oh, nice.
Wait.
They're gonna know.
Don't know.
They'll never know.
Wait.
Up.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to move.
I'm scared.
Wait.
You should die.
I should die?
Okay.
Fine.
Alright.
I'm dead.
Here's an armor swap, Yuris.
There you go.
Did you take my armor swap?
He took mine.
Don't worry, he has like two more.
He has another armor swap.
There you go.
You should die.
I already left.
I'm sorry.
Bro, leave us alone.
You gotta worry about something else.
Oh!
The timing!
They took the building.
Yeah.
At the same time?
Yeah, they did.
They landed as soon as we flew.
Yeah, they got there before us.
One second before us.
Bro.
The fucking timing.
They were going to the tree, but they stopped.
They went back to the building instead.
Yeah.
They knew.
They're like, this is some early, easy K.P.
right there.
We could've fucking fought them though, but you got shot from the height.
Yeah.
I just dived to someone else.
You were just like, come here!
Come here!
I think that Taya is just like 3 meters away from us.
I went to the ping and then I was like, oh wait, Yuris is not at the ping.
Because they got there first.
And then Yuris and I swerved because I was like, there's people there, maybe we shouldn't go there.
Taya, you listen to the IGL too much.
You have to think for yourself.
You have to let your rat brain come in.
And think against the IGL sometimes.
Because Yuris left us to die.
I couldn't get my plus 60 damage.
No, I'm at zero.
We all got zero.
I just want like 100.
That one was the IGL's fault.
I don't know, there seems to be a pattern.
I don't know, it seemed 100% so good.
And then we're just like...
Dead.
We got perpies, we're ready to go.
We looked so healthy and then two different teams shot at us.
It didn't matter.
We couldn't even fight, man.
We got nade, we got stag-nated.
I didn't see the single bullet.
We at least thought it would have been an honorable death but we just died by everyone in the line.
Yeah, everyone just wanted to kill us.
Our booties were just too much.
We just looked so juicy.
That one KP.
The one KP.
The one KP, like look at that.
Easy KP.
How are they not in zone yet?
Who are you guys watching?
I'm watching... I have no idea.
I'm watching a Valk, Bloodhound, Bing.
Yeah, me too.
Who is it?
LinshanSkye.
Oh, we're watching the same thing.
L-Y-K-E.
Like?
Yeah, how do you pronounce the phonetic?
Yeah, yeah.
Like.
Like?
Like that?
Yeah.
That's who we're watching.
Like that, I guess.
Okay, if they win, if this team wins, then we die to the best team in the lobby.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So technically we're first too.
Because we're watching them win.
Yeah, yeah.
We... we...
Oh my god, they're pushing?
Oh, they have to because they're in zone, yeah.
Okay, please don't die.
Oh, this guy is so dead.
Yeah, this guy is dead.
He traded though.
Oh, no!
Holy sh...
Okay, if we watch this play fighting...
Oh, Yukio is dead for sure too.
Oh, Yukio.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, yeah, he is.
Oh, he's so dead.
Bro, what is this zone?
What the f...
Okay, at least it's not...
Oh, he's so dead.
Anytime there's a pylon zone, it's so scary because there's only cover in pylon.
Or is this Bangalore?
Or you guys wanted a solo Bangalore?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The solo Bangalore with Kraber?
Yeah, the solo Bangalore with Kraber?
Yeah, the solo Bangalore.
This is just...
This is just one of them KP, bro.
Oh, my God.
There's a Watson team.
Is Watson meta or are they just fucking big brain?
They knew the zone was gonna be in buildings.
Yuris, this could have been you, man.
This could have been you.
This could have been us.
And we should have ratted here, all of us.
Yeah, just in this corner.
All of us.
We don't shoot our guns.
Yeah, just in this corner.
We just kill this Bangalore and just sit behind this crate.
Oh, my God.
This could have been us.
How did I drop there?
So after this, are we playing duo, trio?
Is it?
I just solo first.
I think it's...
Okay, let me check.
It's solo, and then me and Doki's idiotic adventure.
Wait, it's six games though, right?
Oh, hey, Will!
Will said our translator for... well, my translator because you can't read.
He said that it's gonna be watch for the solo duos.
Someone's gonna do a watch party.
And then like on Discord or something.
And then like we just watch what they're doing so we don't ghost.
Wait, can we talk?
I mean, I'm pretty sure, yeah.
We could just sing so Yuris gets distracted.
We'll IG for Yuris!
Oh yeah, that's cool.
Yeah, give me some ideas.
Yeah, I'm gonna do that.
Yeah, we'll give you some...
Bro, I almost leaked something for the next Apex update.
I caught myself there.
Oh dude.
Oh my god, that could be us.
This dude's a rad professional.
That could be us.
Who is this guy?
Yeah, who is this guy?
I would just mad the fuck up and go around that pillar.
Yeah, let's see that pillar.
That could be us!
Oh my god, that really could be us.
You scaredy-pulled out his gun.
That could have been us.
This is literally just never gonna peak.
It's actually only seven parties.
I bet you this rat is gonna get top five.
Right here.
I think it is.
The teams are fighting right now.
Oh, can everybody get scanned?
If it's not the team in front, then it should be okay, no?
No, it's the team in front.
It's okay.
They see this one rat.
They're just gonna let him live.
They need him.
They need him to live so this guy can help them damage another team.
That's six.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
360, no scope?
He should climb.
He should climb right.
Whoa!
He tried.
Hi there.
Hi.
Yeah.
Oh shit, he should not climb right.
There's so many people.
He's almost top five!
Oh, he's riding.
Holy shit.
Bro, this guy is so smart.
And there's no one on top of him, so...
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, what the fuck?
No, there's someone on top of him.
No!
Oh my god, look at the fucking Hanzo.
Holy shit.
This Watson team just wins for real.
Who is it?
They like hard, they hard grief for that one rat.
They literally all died.
It's Cheeki again, bro.
It's Cheeki.
But Cheeki just knows.
I can't lose.
This man plays so many ranks, like his brain is on another level.
Oh, he's so smart.
He's been trained.
Oh my god.
One few rank grinders.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I'm watching him.
He's so smart.
I was...
Oh my god.
I think Cheeki's got this.
There's no fucking way they lose this.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
This dude check his computer.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Check his PC.
Check his PC, bro.
That is not natural.
Wait, was... did he back to back first place?
Back to back max kill points.
Max kill points.
Oh my god, bro.
This dude is not playing.
He's not.
He is... he's Apex.
Get on and he got off of Violent.
Just give him the prize.
Just give him the prize money already.
Just do it.
He's...
He's Apex.
He's literally Apex.
He should play for a fucking second place.
Yeah, yeah.
We're all...
We all just play for second and third.
Holy...
18.
He had 18 kills.
Oh my god.
And then there's us over there.
Where are we?
We're...
Hey, we're still...
We're never last.
You know.
We're not last though.
We're not last.
Our neighbors are last.
Oh yeah, nice.
Guess what?
Guess who's last.
Yeah, yeah.
Our neighbors are last.
We won against Selly.
More than Selly.
We got...
Look!
We won against Selly!
We're better than Selly.
You're third.
We did better than Selly in the UK.
You're better than Selly, Tayo.
That's already a win.
Our Selly is better.
Zero damage, Selly.
My average for two games is 30 damage.
I put up.
You're right.
You're averaging it up.
I'm not.
30 damage.
We can have that.
Can I have that stat?
Your 30 damage.
After...
After one month of Overwatch...
After one month of Overwatch remember back.
Alright, alright.
It's like, this is your brain on Overwatch.
My brain just can't comprehend zones.
Like, what is this?
I don't understand.
Like, what are you doing?
Where is the Winston bubble?
Like, I need...
Dude, I need some healing.
Where's the support?
Where's our heals?
Where's our Mercy player?
I need the pocket, you know?
The pocket.
Mercy pocket.
I just can't.
I know, you're the Mercy now.
30 damage.
Lowest damage, Gart, is the Mercy pocket.
Dude, I have the lowest damage in this lobby, 100%.
I'm sad.
Last place, like a little bitch.
I'm about to cry.
It's okay.
It's okay, there's no way we have duos after.
There's no way.
Wait, is it already the solo?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, because everybody's leaving.
Are they all kicking us out?
Oh yeah, they're closing.
Yeah.
Okay, Yuris has to screen share.
Okay, I'm ready to watch.
That's the screen share for us.
Oh, they have the code.
Oh yeah, we can join.
Yeah, we can join.
Yeah.
Wait, I feel like...
Okay, but like, what if like, we just watch Yuris?
Like, how do we show that on stream?
Like...
How do I show that on stream?
That's difficult.
Guys, you're just gonna hear us commentate over a blank screen.
Yes guys, we're gonna be commentating on the black screen.
Yeah.
I'm just like, how do I show this?
Wait.
How is that?
Wait, who's on our- the duo's?
Who's on duo- uh...
Selly?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
Selly's part of the duo's.
How is that?
But I have my own Selly right here.
Yes sir, yes sir, I'm ready.
Yeah, my serial damage Selly.
Welcome back.
Okay, Yuris- you have to screen share for us.
Oh no, I have a 1PC setup.
Wait, you guys have multiple PCs?
What's going on?
Okay guys, you won't be able to see what your use is doing on my screen.
So you're just gonna trust my word on everything that's happening.
Oh my god.
How many people are... 20 teams, right?
So I don't leak the code.
Wait, you can have 30 teams of solos?
Holy shit.
Yeah.
I think that's the same as... they're just using duos mode for solo.
They're just force starting it.
What map are you playing?
Limbo... oh shit, wait, where do I land?
Everything is predetermined.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm landing fucking...
Paysriver.
Nice.
Yeah, Paysriver's nice.
Wait, what's your solo character?
I'm playing... Pathfinder.
Playing what?
Pathfinder.
A little Pathfinder fun.
I believe.
A little Widowmaker.
Wait, didn't that new character came out?
What's their name?
Muh... something?
The one that digs in Overwatch?
Oh, Venture?
Yeah, yeah, the Venture of Overwatch.
Oh.
Oh yeah, there's a Venture.
Wait, no, no, no, it's not Venture.
It's fucking Apex.
Yeah, I was gonna say... I mean...
Wait, what?
I'm stupid.
Like, I have a...
It's more something.
I have a brain that's like the size of a peanut, bro.
That's okay, you're an Overwatch player.
Yeah, it's like... it doesn't... like, 1v1 doesn't... like, you need a small brain to be good at Overwatch.
That's true.
You kinda have both.
Yeah, it was a no aim, no brain.
You didn't need to turn on...
...the constant main.
Yeah, just turn off half, like, of your receptors in your brain, and then you'll be good at Overwatch.
Have you tried them out yet?
Yeah, it was really fun.
It was actually a good character.
Like, a dig... are they OP, or is it like...
I mean, sure, I mean...
Because, like, I know Overwatch characters on launch are always, like, overpowered as fuck.
It's either they're overpowered as fuck, or they're like the most useless dog shit ever.
Yeah.
Like, no in between.
That's true.
Wait, why is...
Oh, yeah?
Wait, no, you go first.
No, I was wondering why VDK is here.
VDK?
Team18, he's like a streamer.
Wait, is he the... is he the solo?
Is he...
Yeah.
This is it, Yuri!
Find out where they land!
Everyone's fucking roasting this guy, like, Team18, Lmao.
Yeah.
Team18, really?
Team18?
Yeah.
Bro.
The people in Riddle are bullying Team18.
Yeah, that's their boss.
They're bullying their boss.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
This is their boss.
It's funny.
And their team owner.
They're saying, you're not supposed to be here.
Let them play.
That's funny, though.
Wait, where are you going, Yuri?
You got phase driver.
I got phase driver.
Oh, very nice.
Yep, yep.
Is it the same for... us, too?
No, we're on a different map, right?
Oh, no.
We have a different map.
It's okay.
Yuri's full IGLS.
Oh, yeah, are you allowed to?
Yeah, because, like, he's just going to be watching our screen share.
He's going to watch me whip Tencho's.
Yeah.
He's literally going to come over to my house.
Yeah, because you're going to be too scary, not me.
Yeah.
He's going to come over to my house and beat the fuck out of me.
No, he's going to come over to your house and play on your feet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Turn off your cam.
Yeah, turn off your cam right now.
I'll be like, wow, I'm tired.
Your aim right now is so good.
Wow.
Yeah.
The things we can do, because this is the first time we've played this game, is we will basically be getting the keep-on-trips.
Oh, is he in Japan?
He is.
Just, just take the Uber right now, the Tire's place.
Guys, I'm here.
It's okay.
Oh, is it going to start?
He joins the...
Yurish joins the Discord on his phone, so like, no one will know.
Oh, yeah, smart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it IBM?
Yo, next Scars tournament, we should do that.
Like...
Yeah, I'll pretend like I'm IGLing.
I'm not playing.
Alright guys, I'll...
For people who are like, what the fuck is going on?
Let me pin this message.
Yuris is in a solo match.
Yeah, we're just watching.
And I can't...
And I'm watching via Discord screen share.
Little sculpt set up.
Now let me in, I swear I won't ghost.
I swear I won't tell...
I won't tell people where you are.
I should be allowed to spectate.
Let me in.
Let me spectate.
Dude, I just realized I just fucking suck at this game, man.
You just realized?
C'mon man.
I played a little bit.
It started.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Alright guys.
You're just gonna have...
my commentary next to...
nothing.
Can you guys see it?
Yeah, I'm watching.
Alright.
Yeah, we're watching.
Let's go.
Alright guys, the map is Olympus, by the way.
I mean, your PC's pretty tanky, right?
It can Discord, stream share, and stream, and play Apex at the same time.
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be fine.
Yeah, it's just like, brrroooom.
Just disconnects from Discord.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I turn on the news, and I see his computer on fire with his house.
And everything just blows up.
You know, like, the people who aren't doing Discord screen share, they're serious.
They're actually...
I want every bit of Apex right now.
Holy shit.
Yeah, there's like some people that aren't Discord screen sharing, and then they're just like, they're just like, just watch my stream.
Yeah.
Five second delay, I don't care.
I don't care, just watch the stream.
You're not the pro player here, I don't need the IGL.
Alright guys, wait, okay, you guys are gonna be able to hear the game too, chat, don't worry.
You're gonna be able to hear the game, just not see it.
Okay, your use is tabbed out, so I can't hear the game.
Yeah, I can hear it.
I can't hear anything though.
Yeah, we do.
Oh, you can't hear it?
Yeah.
Oh, no, we can hear it now, don't worry.
No, I think once you start talking, it goes away.
What the fuck?
Oh yeah, what the fuck, that's so weird.
Discord.
Maybe it's just your recent setup.
It just cuts in and out when he talks.
No, no, he needs to be talking.
Like, constantly talk.
Oh wait, I have to be fucking talking for you guys to hear it?
Yeah.
Hey, hey, stop not talking.
Okay.
Does that push the talk on?
And then just have a... get a rock or something and just like...
put a button on it.
Guys, you're gonna hear...
You're gonna hear like some parts of Yuris' fucking gameplay whenever he talks.
Cause that's when the sound comes out.
Wait, why is that a thing?
That's so fucking...
Is it because the server isn't nitro boosted?
Is that why?
Oh, maybe.
Wait, that's a thing?
Bro, I might as... Okay, I'm gonna put your audio on the background from your stream.
It's like a little five minute delay.
Yeah, the little five minute delay.
Oh wait, they're gonna hear like your voice too.
No, I should just watch Yuris' stream on Twitch.
Yeah, but then we're gonna hear his voice on the stream.
Oh yeah, true.
I can mute in Discord.
Oh yeah.
I'm just gonna try.
No, no, you should try.
You need our input.
You need our input here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry.
Wait, you want me to stop streaming on Discord now?
No, no, no.
We wanna watch... I'm watching you on the screens... the share.
Alright, alright.
So yeah, we need that... those five... that five seconds is so important... for us to help you.
That ain't true.
That ain't live.
I'm just... I'm just gonna watch the Discord stream with the scuffed audio.
Alright, where's endgame?
What do you think endgame is?
Oh, do you even have any beacons?
Wait, Yuris muted himself.
Oh wait, never mind.
I do, but... man, my loot is ass.
Can I scan this shit?
You're a robot.
He can't... doesn't he need blue armor for the... picket?
Yeah, I think I need to go level up.
Yeah.
Yeah, you need to use the blue armor first.
Let's go.
Pick up the powder.
Alright guys, don't worry.
I'm gonna play... I'm also gonna play...
I'm gonna get ratted guys.
Just pray for my heart.
I'm praying.
I'm praying for you.
Sorry I zipped there.
Oh, I scanned the fucking...
Don't worry guys, I'm gonna play a game as well while I watch Yuris so it looks like a...
So it looks like we're commentating on my gameplay.
Wait, you can do that?
Wait, what happened to the... what happened to the fucking... drops?
It's just gold... gold and shit.
No, the first... the first drops are gold.
The first one are gold and then...
Oh no, Budoka died!
Oh no!
Yes.
The team owner is dead.
You're supposed to feed the riddle team.
Oh yeah, not fanatic.
Yeah!
You're supposed to feed your teammates.
There's a 20 player in queue and... what the fuck?
There's no one playing Apex?
There's no way... Apex can't be dead.
There's no other game alive right now.
Good aim, yes.
Yes.
Very nice.
Actually this is...
You got a really good drop.
Because you can just farm the... the balls.
Until... until another solo pushes you.
Yeah, there's someone close in that compound.
I'm scared of just getting ratted on carry.
Yeah, solo is like super paranoia.
That's the scariest thing with solos.
Yeah.
Dude, it's a fucking horror game.
It is.
It really is.
It's just so quiet.
Yeah.
At least you don't have white armor anymore.
Because like that's just insta-death as a solo.
Yeah.
Get another phase driver.
They're for sure ratting in that...
How the fuck did like you...
How the fuck did like...
You have found them anyway?
What the fuck?
Did they...
Did you think he actually ran at...
At where the... the team owner's...
Like drop spot was and just to kill him?
Yeah, I mean they...
Yeah, they had to have done that.
Yeah, because I was like...
No way.
I was like how the fuck did he die so fast?
He just walked...
He got like one gun and he's just like I'm ready to beat the shit out of this guy.
I'm gonna take his...
I'm gonna take his loot.
He must have had a good landing spot if they were willing to take his loot.
I think so.
Oh, nice.
Yuris, if you die right now...
You're gonna have the same score as me, unfortunately.
So don't die.
Oh, there's zero damage?
The same score as me.
Our team average is starting to pull down right now.
Our team average.
It's terrible.
Let's get it.
Not last guys.
Not last.
I'm gonna lock there.
Signing shit is actually so scary.
I believe in you.
Did...
Did turbochargers drop from here?
I heard a turbocharger is bad for the Havoc.
It's just like...
In general.
What?
Because...
From the...
I don't know.
A roller player told me this, so I don't know how...
How much I can build.
The source is fucking invalid.
Uncreditable sources.
So I can't...
I can't...
Oh shit, this guy is lurching.
I have a feeling he's like creeping up on me.
Oh no, I have zone?
You have zone?
That's good!
You can keep farming phase.
Hold on, I'm gonna get a position right now.
I'm scared we're gonna get pulled up on here.
I believe.
You're not gonna die.
Yeah, I'm not gonna get rat on, right?
Yeah, there's no way.
If there's a rat, we can go beat him up by a row.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're all Japanese.
I am not involved in this.
I am so far away.
You're automatically...
Yeah, I'm an enabler.
You're like, Doki gave us the idea.
Her NA ways told us to do it.
Oh my god.
I like how you're still farming phase.
Cause you have nothing else to do.
Oh.
There it is.
There's the rat.
Oh, there it is.
We're gonna fight for you.
He's waiting for you to fuck it.
Yeah, let's go drive him shut up.
.
Just killed a rat.
Where is he?
Where'd you go?
This is like a horror movie right now.
Yeah.
The suspense.
I'm scared of getting shot in the side.
Yeah, cause you don't know where the other team players are.
Give me fucking lag shots.
Yeah.
Can I fight this?
Is that getting third party?
Bro, no mate, you did that.
We're either doing the same exact shit...
Yeah, we're like doing the same thing.
I'm playing a game and watching this.
I have the most...
...chance of getting third party.
Wait, did he move?
Yeah, he moved to this building.
I lose that
fight.
He has a little...
...nemesis.
I have a Havoc.
I gotta charge my...
Yeah, you have to charge your...
Yeah, he has the ping diff too.
I mean, you're both in JP though, but...
...he has more shots into you.
Yeah.
I guess you could just chill.
He's not in there though.
Yeah, 100%.
Are we fighting?
Oh, the Sonea's died.
Ooh.
The killer just killed the...
With the repeater in solos.
What the fuck?
That's...
That guy is so confident.
Yeah, that's so confident.
Yeah, that is ballsy.
He's so confident no one's gonna fucking get... like, run up to him.
Holy shit, I can feel my FPS fucking dwingling down.
Oh no.
It's okay, we don't want to screen share.
We'll watch from your stream.
You can just turn it off.
Too late.
I just turned it off.
You're committing it.
But you can always...
You gotta commit.
Oh, stop!
No, that's...
Oh my god, your game sound like... trolled me.
Wow!
No, it wasn't trolled, there was actually people behind me.
Okay.
Good.
Yeah, this site's so sketch.
This game is so sketchy.
It is.
It's a good little cubby.
No one's hiding here, right?
Um, oh.
You can rat.
That's a bad angle.
What do you have?
Oh!
Hey, nice!
Oh, nice!
You can tap me!
Alright, alright, alright.
Let's fucking go!
You're so much better!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, who's this guy?
Getting shot at.
We got this.
Whoa, top 8.
Oh shit, that guy's got a little...
Oh my god.
No!
Yeah, dude, he actually creeped me.
Bro, he got creeped!
He has a little Digi threat, bro.
Yeah, Digi!
Top 8 and a creeper man!
It's okay.
Holy shit, that's a good shot.
Yeah, it was a good shot.
Yeah.
Was it like two different solos or was he the one that...
Were you 1v1ing him?
Nah, it was a 1v1.
He hit the Kraber and then just...
He hit the Kraber and then a 1v1?
He hit the Kraber, yeah.
Once he got that Kraber shot...
It was GG's.
Yeah.
That's insane that he got it.
It was over.
You're just farming points now.
Oh my god.
Yup.
Oh, you kept...
Ah, the Kraber, man.
Dude, everyone's just hiding.
Oh, he's just farming points now.
Yeah, everyone's scared of the Lee Sonic Kraber.
Holy shit.
Wait, that was a blue armor though.
What the heck?
How did he not die?
Yeah.
Not headshot?
No, it was a headshot.
Wait, what?
189.
There he was.
It was 189 to a blue.
What the fuck?
Wait, math?
God damn it.
I got fucking Octane styled on.
Oh yeah, that guy... that guy can't even do anything.
He's just in smoke.
Oh my god.
You can't have a smoke.
He's just actually fucking farming.
Holy shit.
He does not care, bro.
Bro, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
If he hit that, that was so good if he hit that shot.
Yeah.
If he fucking hit that, holy shit.
That would've been a montage.
No, you kept...
Wait, no.
That guy's scared.
That guy got scared.
He got scared.
It's Kraber, we...
Why are you so scared?
Dude, he's on the boat.
Bro, bro.
He's so...
Wait.
What the fuck?
He's on the boat.
Oh my god.
He has...
No!
You can't.
He's dead.
Yeah.
1v1.
It's a Rev 2.
What the fuck is that?
What is he holding?
What does he have?
Does he have like a Bangalore Heirloom?
No, that's the new Heirloom, the knife thing.
Oh my god.
He fucking destroyed him too.
Holy shit.
Oh, the fucking Horizon Q.
The Horizon Q.
Oh, the Havoc beam.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
All right.
Wait.
Why did that guy not use his ult?
Where's the Rev?
He got scared.
Wait, my Apex crashed.
I just realized.
Oh, thank god you crashed now instead of...
Oh god.
Yeah, yeah.
Man, that sucks.
Losing to a...
I hate losing to a fucking Kraber.
He better have...
It's okay.
It's like...
Almost like you got third place.
You know?
It's almost like...
That is true.
I mean you started on that one guys.
That's all that matters.
That's what matters.
I won my 1v1 to Tapii.
Yeah, remember he won his 1v1.
That's what matters.
That is what matters guys.
That's all that matters.
He won the 1v1 guys.
He won the 1v1.
Oh no, my Apex is crashing like a madman.
Oh no.
Wait.
Not now.
Not now we have duels.
Well, I'm gonna leave this fucking quick play game.
I'll watch you guys now.
It's my time to ideal.
Yeah, you gotta ideal us.
Okay, there's a new lobby code.
Alright, I'm sorry to this one team.
Good luck.
Good luck randoms.
Hopefully it doesn't crash.
No crash please.
Rise of Hayao?
You have like, you always have problems with it.
Yeah, no I always crash.
Right?
It's like always been like this with Hayao.
It's like they don't want me to play.
It's like the Apex is like known to be, you know, not the greatest monetized game, optimized game out there.
You know, the optimization is just not the best.
They just want me to go back to Overwatch.
That's so fucked up.
Okay, where are we landing?
Wait, where are we landing?
Duos...
Olympus... one...
Oh, FaceDriver.
Oh, we got FaceDriver too!
We're gonna share FaceDriver.
Is it also?
Is it actually?
Is it not?
Yeah, I think it's exactly the same.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I hope they don't start yet.
Wait, wait, what comp do we play?
Coach!
Actually, wait, wait, wait.
I've learned this from experience.
Duo is way fucking sweatier.
Like, it's actually like a trio game.
So, something that could like get in, you know, like a little get in zone.
Like a...
Valak Blood or Valak Bang.
Maybe Valak Blood for like the scan, you know?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna leave the lobby.
And I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
Okay.
Yo, me too.
Yuris, entertain our chat.
What the heck?
Hey guys!
What the fuck is happening?
Entertaining.
Yeah, you guys enjoying this tournament?
Um...
Light...
Like and subscribe in the channel.
If you haven't subscribed.
How do you entertain a fucking chat?
Usually chat just entertain themselves.
Streamer...
Listen, listen, listen.
This is what I think, alright?
I think a chat...
Chat is like an embodiment of their streamer.
I think...
How you are a streamer reflects your chat.
So, what's going on here?
How is Doki's...
Chat right here?
How are you?
What would you guys describe yourself?
Tomatoes.
I see.
Gaslighters.
We like yapping.
Oh god.
Oh shit.
I'm running.
I'm running back.
Why were you like, oh shit.
Oh god.
You started moving.
I saw.
I wanted to know what you were saying.
I wonder what Yurisa is going to do to entertain.
Okay, what do I do?
Okay, blood valk.
Okay.
I feel like we got to stick together.
Because I feel like if we are separated, they are going to pick us off so fast.
Yeah, I'm a stupid person.
That is a good strat.
I have... that's revolutionary.
Yeah, yeah.
We just got to stick together so we don't individually get picked off.
We just got to make sure we have blue armor by the time someone rolls up on us.
That's true.
Look at the sky.
Yurisa got like super lucky with the zone too.
It like literally pulled onto him.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I actually hate having zones in solo.
Wait, oh I guess like solos are scarier.
Yeah, because you can't just walk up.
Yeah, yeah.
You can't walk up to people.
You have to actually...
You have to actually like look around.
Yeah, I'm the one that got walked up.
Yeah, yeah.
I get that, yeah.
Okay, it's okay.
If we have zones as duos, then it will be better.
Wait, there's Cheeki?
Yeah, yeah.
Cheeki is the content creator.
Oh yeah, you guys are playing against Telly.
Yeah, yeah.
Is Telly a Cheeki?
Yeah.
You guys excited?
What's the confidence looking like?
I'm so confident.
You know what?
We're better.
We're so much better.
Like I might not have never got rank 1, but we're so...
I might have averaged 30 damage per game, but I'm just better.
Listen, it's time to up it out right now.
Is it?
I believe in you, Tayo.
You're literally the best.
You're literally supposed to be like the Cheeki of our team.
I'm ready to just...
I'm ready to click on the phase driver thing.
Yeah, yeah.
That's like my main goal.
You know, I have advice.
You know like...
Just click the phase driver.
I wish you could get armor off of that.
Just clicking the button over and over again.
Yeah, just like 50.
I'm like, I'm just gonna click the button.
50, 50, 50.
Plus 50, plus 50.
What are we waiting for?
Wait, why is team 10 three people?
What the fuck?
Wait a minute.
What is that?
Yo.
Are you gonna stream?
Are you gonna watch our stream?
I'll watch your stream.
Yeah, we're not gonna...
I can't...
Can't IGL with a little delay, huh?
Can you see this one?
It's okay.
Maybe Tyler's PC is much more optimized.
Oh shit, there's code right there.
Can you see this?
Did you leak the code?
No, no, no.
I never do that.
I never leak.
Oh shit, there's a code right there.
I don't know.
I heard, oh shit.
There's a code right there.
That does not give me confidence.
It was to his bank account.
It's not a thing too big.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just his bank account.
That's fine.
Wait, wait.
Okay, now there's two.
Okay.
We're starting.
Literally, if we kill Cheeki, I'm expecting $100,000 in the bank account by tomorrow.
That's just all I'm saying.
Like, Scars...
If I kill this man...
Destroyer.
Destroyer, come help him right now.
What's it?
Destroyer69.
Alright.
Wait, where's FaceDriver?
I'm scared.
Daddy!
You're a GLS Jumpmaster.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, there you go.
I was gonna say, I'm not being mad, Maggie.
Wait, can I...
Actually, no.
I don't know.
I would say bang, but...
He said, he said, blood...
Blood... Well, I have scans for you, right?
Because, like, I scan, and then...
And then you shoot them, right?
Yeah, that's the plan.
That's the plan.
That's what we said.
Okay, this is where you boost up your average.
That's true.
This is the average boosting count.
You're my hype man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I believe.
Okay, FaceDriver is...
Right... Where?
There?
No, there it is.
Yeah, there.
I see it.
Okay, I'm dropping...
Eventually... Oh, wait.
Okay.
What's the fastest way?
Is it like 700, 600?
I think someone told me.
Yuris?
Coach!
Wait, Coach!
Don't leave us, Coach!
Is he not allowed to talk?
Yeah, he should be.
He's just watching us.
Wait, what the fuck?
I can't talk when I'm watching the stream.
Bro, what's wrong with your Discord?
Your Discord is bugged.
Bro, we're just like, Coach, Coach!
How do I do that?
I guess you're just gonna be watching...
No, no, it's a bug.
It's a bug.
There's nothing you can do.
Wait, it is?
I can't fix it?
You have to reinstall Discord or something, I think.
What the fuck?
What is wrong with your Discord?
I've been talking the entire time.
He hasn't been trying to coach you.
No, you are not, Coach.
I pressed the button.
I'm pulling out the Sentinel.
Bro!
It's Duo's!
Why are you pulling out the Sentinel?
Is this not a valid strat, Coach?
Coach, we need your help.
Coach!
I watched your stream.
Is Sentinel not a valid option?
Listen, if you hit your shots, it's any gun, bro.
True.
And what was the fucking track record?
The last two games?
30!
I'm saying it again.
I didn't shoot.
That is true.
I guess you can say that.
I pressed the face driver.
We need to get armors.
I'll scan later.
Oh yeah.
We really need armors.
We can't be going in there with our whiteys.
I'm gonna pull out the Peacekeeper.
Oh, there's a helmet here.
Yes, sir.
Okay.
Okay, Tyra's stream is like two seconds delayed.
That's fine.
Yeah, okay.
That's good.
That's fine.
That should be easy.
You can remove the stream on Discord now.
Yeah, you can get your ping.
Get the little FPS.
My computer is too strong.
It does not care.
Whoa!
Humble brag.
Go for it, bro.
I'm gonna go scan then.
Can you cover me just in case?
Yes, yes, yes.
I'm coming.
Alright.
What else can we do to grab our...
Oh, wait.
We have to grab the...
Do you guys not have harvesters inside?
Yeah, we do.
We have one here.
I'm gonna scan right now just to make sure we're okay.
Hopefully it's just not cheeky.
Yeah, we can get the Evo.
Look around where everyone's trying to play.
Where are they trying to play?
No clue.
No fucking clue.
What is this?
You can scan the drop style right now.
Okay.
If you look at the sky.
Wait, where are they?
I think they all already dropped.
Oh, I'm stupid.
Where's zone ending?
Where do we go?
I'm curious.
Just loot towards the circle for now.
Take your time.
And play for the next zone.
Okay.
I dropped a 3x.
Once you see the next zone, find a little...
I'm gonna use 2.
And then you guys play for that.
Oh, no.
I don't know the new system of beacons and shit.
Like...
I thought I could scan it.
Yeah.
No.
Val can't, right?
I don't remember.
Yeah, because I don't play Val.
So I don't know if Val can.
I did the phase again.
Just look at cheeky stream.
It's a joke, guys!
It's a joke, but it was a joke.
Turning off echo cancellation.
I hear a car, I hear a car.
Behind us.
I think they're scanning, right?
Yeah, yeah.
But can we see the scan from here?
Yeah, we can.
We should be.
We're not scanning.
I don't see them.
I heard a car.
Did they drive past us?
I mean, we have a car, but...
Wait, wait, no, they did!
They just scanned!
They're literally in town.
They're on the car.
I think they're just gonna wrap around, right?
Yeah, they should.
Right?
We have a car, too.
Where's the closest beacon right next to you guys?
Which one?
I don't know.
Which one's the beacon?
Go to solar array.
Should we take the car to solar or just walk over?
Nah, just walk over.
Loot everything.
There's no one near us because I have a crow.
Usually there's a crow to shoot.
They're still behind us, though.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
They're in front of us.
Can I shoot?
Get that harvester.
Are they gonna shot from here?
Yeah.
Move left towards the entrance of terminal.
Okay.
Are we gonna get that?
Yeah.
I think they're just going around driving.
They're...
People over there.
I have ult.
We need to fly.
If they start fighting, you can third party them.
But if they don't commit, we don't have...
They're not committing.
There's a team right here.
There's a team to my right.
I'm worried I'm getting shot from our back.
I don't see them.
Where are they shooting?
Where are you guys?
In my discord crowd.
Dude, I think I'm higher.
What's going on here?
Guys, what's going on?
What's going on, guys?
Everything's going right.
We can fly.
Look at the zone.
Where's the zone?
The zone is Growtower's.
Growtower...
Here you go.
Is there a team on Solar?
Yeah, there is.
Look at how they're...
What they're doing.
They're not scanning the beacon.
I don't know if they have beacon characters.
That's the thing.
I think you guys take Solar from them.
If they're not there, they're not gonna be able to...
They're not gonna be able to...
We don't know who they are, though.
Walk up from the right and then...
The right, okay.
Let's go right side.
I believe in us.
Guys, play for that beacon.
You can even tank a little bit of zone as well.
Alright.
One minute.
Oh my god, they knocked somebody.
They're in front of us.
They're scanning.
They're scanning us.
We're here.
Back up.
They're going in the house.
Are they running?
I can't believe we're so lucky.
Like the pills in front of you.
Oh, never mind.
No, he has teammates.
No!
He had teammates!
Oh, if I was there with you!
If I was there with you, man!
Yeah, you actually fucked them over.
You creeped them.
Bro!
I can't believe!
Ever since Tayo crashed, everything went downhill.
It's a great hit.
It hit all of us.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Bro, you actually used the Peacekeeper like Ash.
That is crazy.
Yeah, bro, you should just play Peacekeeper.
This is hard scope.
Yeah, the hard scope!
Ash hard scope.
Oh my god.
That's so unlucky.
That's what you get for trying to fuck over a solo man.
Nah, that is so fucking unlucky, man.
I know.
In duels!
I've never... I've only had...
This is the second blue screen I've ever had on Apex.
It had to happen now.
It had to happen in the duels.
Man, it had to happen now.
Yeah.
That's actually crazy.
My second ever blue screen of death.
I'm sorry.
The next stop is your ease, unfortunately.
Yeah, your ease already got hit with the fucking Discord.
Wait, stop.
Not me.
Oh yeah, the Discord bullshit.
Yeah, yeah.
What is that, bro?
What is that?
What's up Discord bugs, guys?
What's going on here?
We have three more games.
It's okay, we can bring it back in the next three games.
I believe.
Wait, there's three more games?
I wanna go for ten.
Yeah, yeah.
No, two more games.
Yeah, there's two more games.
Two more trios.
Bro.
Redo the duels match.
I crashed.
Restart.
Yeah, redo please.
Thank you.
Wait, this game is actually like...
Oh my god.
This game really wanted Taya to have more damage.
Yeah.
How much damage did I have?
This game wanted him to have a higher damage.
So they fucking sent out the assassins on me.
They're average, so they fucking sent out the assassins on me.
In the middle of the road tape too.
I was like, what the fuck?
It's so messed up.
Maybe we're just meant to be Overwatch players.
Yeah.
This game is just telling us we suck ass.
Yeah, like...
Wait, Yuris, what's your Overwatch rank?
I got point to gold.
You got gold?
My first rank.
Yeah.
You're gold?
That shit was a scam, bro.
Bro, what do you mean?
You get 10 matches.
My rank got scammed.
You get 10 matches to rank up.
What are you, looting placements?
Bro, it's so cute.
Yeah, I got point to gold.
I got point to gold after my placement.
Wait, what's your rank now?
I did like 7-3.
And all those games, I did good.
It wasn't like I trolled one of the games.
It's just I had bad teammates.
Oh, the Overwatch special.
Yeah, yeah.
I just had bad...
That sounds like a typical DPS main.
Yeah, I did it.
I am indeed a DPS main.
I just can't.
What more can I do?
What's that rank?
What's that crazy game?
I got trolled once by a healer.
Oh my god.
You're in elo hell, bro.
It's not you.
It's your teammates.
That's why you're stuck in elo hell.
But like, I actually was like...
Actually, I'm like...
I like...
I don't think I should be in gold.
You know?
Like, I platinum at least.
At the very least.
Did you rank up the play or are you still in gold?
I stopped after I got trolled by a healer.
I like... yeah.
Fuck this.
I'm not playing this game anymore.
I actually...
I actually raged... went to Valorant and raged in Valorant.
No.
That's called you should stop streaming.
Because if you know...
If you had to go to Valorant after rage quitting Overwatch, that's when you know you need to stop.
Valorant is not better.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Gold is like the average...
average player.
You're average.
That's the average rage.
I'm average.
I just need a duo.
You know?
I need like... I need someone to rage with me.
I need someone to like...
I need someone to be there.
You need...
No.
You need a mercy pocket.
That's what you need.
Bro, I actually... I think I have a mercy pocket.
I'm about to duo with a friend.
We're about to roll...
We're about to get the diamond.
You need the mercy pocket.
That's it.
The healer pocket.
That's the way.
Oh my god.
This team...
Oh, this team.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That's the team that killed me.
That's the team that killed you?
No.
Because they died.
It's the team that killed the people that killed me.
That makes me the best.
Yeah.
That makes you the best.
The second...
I think I'm the best.
Who is this team?
Someone in my chat was like, every gold player say they belong in diamond.
Dude, my gym coach says the same shit.
I'm in gold, but I deserve diamond, bro.
My teammates.
The moment you get that mercy pocket, you go up.
Yeah.
I feel like there's actually moments where you cannot do... like you can't do more.
As a solo though.
Well, to be fair, I think like Overwatch...
Overwatch has changed.
Because in the past, you can...
You can solo carry a team.
In the past when there was like six players.
Now like... Now the way they balanced in Overwatch 2, I feel like it's harder to solo carry.
If you're like a fucking god tier DPS.
Yeah, it's...
You just die.
Yeah.
Especially if you're a DPS player.
If you really want to climb, being a tank...
Okay, but tank is... Playing tank is fucking miserable.
But like...
No one really enjoys playing tank.
But like, tank is like the most overpowered character now in Overwatch.
I think DPS got like hella nerfed.
I always get fucking rolled by that guy that has the little punching...
The guy that punches.
Doomfist?
Yeah, Doomfist.
I always get fucking fisted by that guy, bro.
I hate him.
Wait, what?
Yeah, you got fisted.
Several times.
We have a 10 minute interval.
I'm gonna go to a fucking lockdown.
You're gonna go to lockdown?
What the fuck does that mean?
Wait, let's lockdown.
Let's lockdown together.
I need to fucking roll someone right now or I'm about to lose it.
Oh my god, wait, yeah, yeah, that's all.
Wait, you guys don't have me at it?
Okay.
I leave custom mesh.
I'm here.
Is this just Dokkaebird?
Yeah.
I'm here now.
Oh my god.
What is lockdown?
Oh, what the fuck?
I can't even play.
Wait, what?
Oh, the curse!
The curse is real!
The curse is the next step.
She's level one.
She's like level one.
What do you mean?
I'm 107.
Yeah.
I think it's you.
Wait, is it my fault?
Yeah, it's you.
Go to firing range.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gonna go in?
We have to leave because it resets it.
Okay.
Yeah, it's a little LGS strat there.
I'm not too versed in the Apex Apex phenomenon.
Yeah, we've learned to adapt to the bugs.
It's not bugs anymore, it's features.
It's like how in Overwatch you turn on V-Sync on and off.
That's the equivalent.
I don't even think that shit worked.
Dude, punch boosting is definitely back.
Holy shit.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's back.
Oh man, like you know how were you- you played Overwatch since launch, right Tayo?
Yeah.
Yeah, remember that phase where you had to delete your friends for more FPS?
You remember that?
Oh yeah, that was a thing.
That shit was so funny.
You don't have too many friends in your friends list.
Yeah, yeah, you have to like keep your friends list to like one to two pages because you can get more friends so people have to do that in Overwatch.
It's like yeah, you have too many friends, you're getting fucking nerfed.
Yeah, you're like are you a good enough friend to like to for the frames?
Okay.
That shit was so dumb.
Yeah, yeah, we go back to lobby.
And then Yuris crashes, right?
That's the whole plan.
Yeah, yeah, he's gonna crash in the next game.
Wait, not trios.
Lockdown.
Okay.
Wait, he's still- oh, okay, it's good.
Yeah, it's good now.
Oh my god, I thought it was some bug.
Yeah, frames were for friends, 100%.
To be fair, even if like, you know, Overwatch 2 has gone through a lot of things, the best thing about Overwatch is the fact that you literally play any server and you're fine.
The netcode for this fucking game is like insane.
True, true.
It's one good thing, I guess.
Yeah.
Out of the many bad- Out of the many bad truths.
But then again, any game- no game is perfect, honestly.
Yeah, yeah.
100%.
I just wish there would be a new FPS game.
I've been like, I don't know.
There's like this- I don't know if you guys heard about the one that's from like RuneScape devs.
I know, it's weird that RuneScape devs are making an FPS game, but- Wait, what?
There was a new one that beta opened.
Oh, The Ascendant!
Have you guys heard about it?
The Ascendant?
Ascendant?
Yeah.
No, let me Google it.
Apparently like closed beta is coming out like tomorrow or something, or today.
The Ascendant?
The Ascendant FPS?
Yeah.
Have you guys heard about that game?
Infinity?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Apparently it's by some fucking RuneScape dev.
It's like Apex Movement with like- Yeah, it looks like Apex.
Yeah, it's like Apex Movement with something else.
I don't remember.
I saw it on Twitter.
It was like trending on Twitter.
And I was like, oh my god.
This game's gonna die in like two weeks, but oh my god.
Just like the finals.
Oh my god.
I wanna kill people right now.
What's Lockdown?
What game mode is this?
I don't think I've played Lockdown.
No clue.
Who's that one last player that's not loading in?
Do I need to buy someone an SSD right now?
Yeah!
Give me your address, boy!
Let me send you a terabyte SSD.
Troll.
Oh, what's your rank right now, Tayo?
Right now?
Like Grand Master something.
One- or...
Not even that new rank they made?
What's that new rank they made?
There's like 10 people in that rank.
Like- there's 10 people in champion?
It's legit like 15 people per region per role.
Wait, really?
This is like, not top 500, it's like a tier above... a tier...
No, like, top 500 is like from Masters 1.
Ohhhhhhhhhh!
Bro, that means champion is like fucking top 10, or top 15.
Yeah, it's like... it's really like... I don't know, I'm never getting there.
I'm never getting there.
Bro, what the fuck?
I did not realize that fucking... that's like top 10.
That's hella hard.
You need a 3 stack or some shit.
Yeah, at 3 AM when there's no one playing it, you just kill all the Masters.
The Overwatch League special.
Oh shit, I'm getting rolled.
I rolled one guy.
I didn't shoot anything yet.
I don't know where people are.
What the fuck?
That's what Bloodhounds... woah.
Oh, he's above me!
Guys, I'm feeding.
Oh shit.
I'm feeding.
They're holding the spot.
Yeah, I think you gotta go to the spot.
The spot?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm so... ohhhh, like do you like... oh, it's like control, basically.
Yeah, there's... there's a guy above you.
Wait, where did the guy go?
The fuck?
Right below us.
Alright guys, we're gonna take her.
Underneath me.
Dead.
I just fucking fell.
It's fine, I'm fucking falling before you.
Oh, that's not you.
Okay.
Nice.
I don't care.
I'm healing.
They literally have like infinite bubbles.
Go in!
Go, go, go, go!
I'm pushing left.
I'm scanning, I'm scanning!
I got one!
I cracked two.
I got two!
Woah, that's another...
I got three!
Nice!
I can't get more!
I cracked two!
I did everything I can.
What the fuck?
Oh, they have replay now.
There's just like four parties now.
Yo, we're getting fucking...
We're bears.
Okay, we're second.
Wait, wait, wait, go B, go B, go B.
Go B?
It's neutral, it's neutral.
I'm heading over.
This is like some... wait, we're playing Overwatch right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're controlling the point.
I'm literally running past as many people.
I'm... ooh!
What the fuck?
Hello, he's on my door.
Oh, he burned me!
I'm so ass-cheeked.
Okay, I'm healing.
Don't worry, they're not gonna push, right?
Outside?
Wait, in front of me.
No audio!
Oh god.
He's climbing up on you!
You can climb that?!
What the fuck?
There's a flipper in the roof!
Hopi, Hopi!
No!
I had to fucking...
charge it up!
Bro, when did they add a replay?
Did you just add it today?
Or like, not on lockdown?
Nah, I think it's for this game mode, maybe.
Oh, they're testing it out, it must be.
Oh my god, dude, I can't beat the dude with the prowler.
I'm heading over to neutral.
I'm heading over to B.
I'm in.
Are you not supposed to scope for...
the prowler?
The prowler?
You can, but not really.
Bruh.
I normally don't.
Oh my god.
I hate this guy.
Hate is a strong word, man.
I'm going to dokey.
There's people on me, there's people on me.
I'm going to B.
Let's meet up in B.
Oh, there's two people on me.
There's no one to scope for.
Oh no, my wingman.
They have my wingy.
What the fuck was this guy?
Okay.
I'm dead.
Let's go B.
It's okay, I'm scanning.
I realize we're so far.
Yeah, yeah, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B.
I'm dead.
What the f- I'm getting teamed on by five teams.
You get teamed?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I got one.
Okay, they're all in there.
The backup's here.
Back up here, back up here.
We need the backup.
That's us, let's get shot in the back.
Wait, I'm pushing from the left.
I'm flanking, I'm flanking.
Yeah, me too, me too, me too.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's low.
Flash on me, dead.
I'm going to buy in the corner.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, I had to make sure that...
What is happening to that guy?
That blob has started it.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I'm sweaty as fuck.
Dead bitch.
You're dead.
They're coming in, they're coming in, they're coming in.
One guy on me.
Did we get it?
There's so many guys.
Oh my god, it's neutral.
I got it, I got it.
You got it?
Okay, I'm covering, I'm covering.
There's people on the bubble.
I'm holding it, I'm holding it.
I'm here.
He's behind you.
Nice.
Got one.
Thank you.
On me.
Got him.
Oh my god, we're fucking owning right now.
Next.
There's wingy, there's wingy.
Where's the wing?
I got it, I got it.
You can use it, just use it.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's four people on A.
Guys!
They're gonna take the wingy!
They took the wingy.
Wait, just go to A, no?
I'm literally on A.
Yeah, just take A.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Phew.
Nice, free zone.
I just wanna hide.
Where the heck we got a free zone?
Yeah, we got a free zone.
Rowan.
Nice.
How long does this game mode end?
Two, two, two, two.
Two on height, two on height, two on height.
Gibby, Gibby right here.
Okay.
I'm scanning.
I'm going up.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
I'm moving up.
I'm coming.
I got one.
Yeah, I can see him, I can see him.
Oh nice.
You got cross 50.
Wait, going up.
I'm gonna grab that triple take.
Oh, there's an EV, there's an EV!
I'm gonna grab it actually.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I'm air support.
I'm under zip, under staircase.
Well, I dropped out guys.
Wait, this isn't even our point anymore.
Yeah, yeah, we have to go to B.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah, we have to go to B.
I was like, what are you guys doing?
What happened?
I'm just chucking nades in there.
Alright, it's neutral.
I'm going in.
Yeah, going in.
There's one guy, there's one guy.
Oh, that's you.
Nice.
There's a wingman.
Oh my god.
I will that guy.
Wingman.
Wingman right here.
I need to heal.
I can't see anything.
Sully, go do your silly thing.
Behind me.
I'm good now.
I'm giving up the point.
What do you mean?
I'm still on it.
Why did you give up?
Wait, we're winning.
Wait, we're winning guys.
How do you win?
We need 500.
We're so close.
Keep going.
Oh, we're not winning.
We are.
We need like 30.
I'm going A.
We're literally 30.
We need A.
Oh, you're dying boy.
Oh, I'm so dead.
Oh, just grab A.
We're literally...
Come to me.
I'm holding it in for 4 seconds.
Did we do it?
Come on.
Wait, we won.
Oh my god.
Wait, we saw the...
Wait.
We won something.
You know what?
No matter what happens in the tournament, we won in lockdown.
We won this.
I was sweaty as fuck.
This is our win.
Just in time too.
We have 5 minutes to match.
Wait, we still have 5 minutes?
No, no.
Yeah, we have like 5 minutes to match.
I don't think we can get another lockdown in guys.
I almost did it.
We have a storm point again.
What happened in our last storm point game?
Remember when we tried to land and then like another team landed on our spot?
Yeah, that's what happened.
Did you just relive the PTSD?
Yeah.
Yeah, I had to start a race from...
Do you guys want a shotgun 1v1?
A shotgun 1v1?
It's starting soon.
Yeah, everyone's in.
I can't even move there.
Wait, someone move me.
Where's the code?
I'm gonna leave again and then join back in.
There we go.
There's the code.
I joined back.
Oh yeah, I need someone to move me.
Wait, what the fuck?
I can't move, yeah.
I'm fucking stuck.
Don't keep burning.
Sad.
Team 1 please.
Can't move.
Put me in, coach.
Sad.
I'm stuck.
Coach!
Get me off the bench, coach.
Please.
Let me play.
They put me in the sad corner.
It's okay.
We're not the last team to join the lobby.
Exactly.
Well, technically we're here already, yeah?
Yeah, we're all here.
I'm just not on a team because I'm stuck.
Hey, there you go.
I'm stuck, bro.
Azath.
I'm gonna go get a snack for your back.
Alright.
Snack break.
Full snack break.
What games have you been playing, Yuris?
Other than Overwatch and Valorant.
Is it just those three?
Uh...
Yeah, I thought you were not gonna fucking include Valorant.
I'm like, yeah, I could Valorant too.
To be fair, there's no other FPS games right now.
I just do some...
Yeah, I just do some IRL streaming.
You guys were at karaoke yesterday, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dude, that shit was sick.
That's true.
Like, the karaoke's in Japan is like insane.
There's like two so much shit you can do there.
We were with, um...
like a professional singer.
Like, actually, like...
Damn!
He like makes like anime music.
Oh shit, like what anime?
Um...
Every anime.
The specific anime is Namara Menkyou Dosankou A Cute Hokkaido Girl.
Um...
He makes... What do you call that?
Overkill?
What is that anime?
What is it?
Overkill?
I heard that name is familiar.
Overkill.
Overload.
Overload, yeah.
That's pretty sick.
Oh, so he does like the...
Wait, he does like the opening?
For Overload?
Yeah.
Oh shit!
That's sick.
Yeah, yeah.
It's surprising how like many like famous...
OXC as well.
How many like famous Japanese celebrities play Apex.
I do... I know!
It's actually absurd.
It's crazy, yeah.
I remember that one tournament, I just finished watching, um...
Alice in the Borderland.
Yeah.
And the guy was playing in it.
I'm like, wait, I just finished watching that show!
One of the main characters playing Apex!
He's in... he's in my fucking game?
Like...
He's in my game, bro!
Like wait...
That's crazy.
He's playing with uh, Jim Burton and...
Oh, shit!
That's actually insane.
Yeah.
That's so cool.
I remember like when I was in...
When I was in Japan, like I went to like the, uh...
I went to like the Apex...
The Apex fucking cafe.
And then I saw like a bunch of girls taking like, like aesthetic photos with their like Apex Legends acrylic stands with their food.
And I was like, They were like... they were like super fashionable too.
I was like, holy shit!
Like, I did not realize like... Like I knew Apex was popular, but I didn't know it was like that popular type deal.
Where people were taking like actual like aesthetic photos and stuff with their food.
Mhm.
Yeah.
We're not all stinky gamers anymore!
Yeah, like bro, it's not just gamers!
It's not just...
Yeah... Yeah...
What am I playing?
Valkyrie?
I guess we're going to the same comp, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Same comp, same comp.
Hopefully we land in a place that isn't full of people that just landed as well.
Yeah, isn't.
Yeah.
But listen, we had the same, you know, thoughts.
They were just like a little faster.
Yeah, we were like 10 seconds faster.
They would have been fucking in the bin.
Yeah, if we were there first, yeah.
We hesitated.
I would have like 500 damage at that point, like god damn.
Okay.
More than 60 damage.
Oh, same.
Yeah, same.
But this isn't the last, right?
No, no, we have one game after that.
Please.
If there is a god of Apex Legends.
Give us some...
More than 60 damage.
Okay, I think for that to happen, one of us has to crash.
Wait, I don't think that's the Apex Legends...
I don't think it has...
It's up to the Apex Legends gods.
It's up to you, Ty.
It's up to you.
No, no, like, you guys don't understand my struggles.
You'll never understand me.
It's never my fault.
Can I land here or is that off-limits?
I feel like... I mean, you don't want to get shot by these.
You could land there and do the...
do the dogs.
Yeah, just don't die.
I'm scared.
Are you a pussy?
Are you a little bitch?
Yes!
I'm a little bitch, what do you want?
I'm scared as fuck.
I'm scared as fuck!
Typical Overwatch player.
Little bitch.
Overwatch player being a little bitch?
I dropped the nemesis.
Typical.
If anyone wants a nemesis.
I'm a...
have a locker myself.
Let's see.
I need like... if anyone finds a vault, let me know and they don't want it.
Yes sir!
Alright.
Let's see.
It's okay.
We are...
Hey, it's the same... it could be same zone?
It's literally the same circle.
Yeah, they love that fucking pylon zone, huh?
It looks literally the same as the last Stormpoint game.
Oh, scan by survey beacon.
Oh, we are scanned by here.
Oh, good thing I land there.
Holy shit.
I mean, you'd be...
Yeah, no, no.
You would land here.
They are like here.
What do you mean?
Yeah, that's your ping, I think.
That was your ping.
Uh...
I dropped a purple...
laser sight.
I'll take that.
Okay, I need a backpack though.
Low key kind of...
kind of here without a bag.
Oh, I found...
Oh, is that backpack?
Yeah.
There's a bag here.
Thank you.
Try to find a vault.
I have an L-star carbine.
Did you loot the back yet?
Yeah, I...
Where's that...
What do you call this thing?
Holy shit.
Laser sight.
I forgot the fucking attachment.
I dropped...
I dropped it like all the way over the back there.
The purple one?
I don't know if Taya got it.
Did you already got the laser sight?
No, I didn't pick it out.
It's all yours.
There it is.
Oh, please.
Alright, we should go over here and then scan the beacon and grab this.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Oh, there's your hair and a lightning rod.
I'm heading over.
Heading over.
Let me see, uh...
Ultimate accelerant.
I have one.
I have an ultimate accelerant.
I'm holding one right now.
I just need a fucking vault.
I have an L-star.
I'm using a b-b-b-b-b-b-bolt as well.
Alright.
I can make do with an L-star for now.
Wait, there's a...
Is there a package behind us?
No, that's a crow, JK.
JK.
I looked at my map and I was like, wait a minute.
Got my drop.
Gamer here.
Oh, you should scan the drops to Tayo and...
Wait, I can scan them?
Yeah, the drops.
Well, well, well, if you see it on the sky.
I'm gonna scan.
See where they're rotating.
We should do the same rotating.
We go up there.
Oh my god.
They're all here.
This looks like our launch pad zone, guys.
What do you think?
I don't think I listen.
There's like... There's only... There's no one around us, too.
Uh...
The closest... The closest... I'm coming up.
...scan is here.
Uh...
Oh, yours all went up.
I'm coming back.
I wanted to...
Yeah, yeah.
I am 10 seconds behind.
We're gonna play for this beacon scan.
You want me to give you the bolt?
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
I can work with L-Star.
I got good... I have a carbine.
I found a peacekeeper, so...
Oh, okay.
I can grab it.
Oh, it's right here.
Alright.
It's open here.
There were people in Command Center.
They might have rotated from there.
Yeah.
Regret... Regretty the decision.
Um... Still far.
Still don't get into a fight.
I am waiting.
I wanna do the...
speeder.
Oh, wait.
They probably did it.
Ah, no.
It's still here.
Okay.
I'm gonna do it now.
I'm almost there.
I have no big medkits.
Um... I have two medkits.
I can give you one.
I think two... I have two as well.
I'll just take one from you, Houston.
Give me it!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
He might...
Thank god.
We're not 20th.
That's all that matters.
Oh, yeah.
They did... they did...
They did the fucking... eggs.
Whatever these things are called.
I'm gonna do the...
Oh, don't scan the beacon right away.
Yeah.
Let's do this... let's do the spiders.
And then we... The door's open, by the way.
Yeah.
Sketchy.
Pretty sketch.
Bat here.
This too.
Uh... I'll take the bat.
I don't have any bat.
Oh.
I don't have a bat.
A drug.
Yeah.
I'm a little broke.
Alright.
Go for the beacon scan.
I'll go back for the beacon.
Not last, baby.
Not last again.
Let's go.
We're consistent.
We're doing really good right now.
Yeah, we're consistent.
Very consistent.
Where do we go?
Oh, yeah.
It's definitely launchpad.
Nice.
Alright.
We're good.
Um... Team there.
Team about to be here.
They're probably gonna rotate down.
Do we command center jump or...
Um... Nah.
I think we just...
go down normally.
And then go...
I wanna get this, to be honest.
Which one?
This?
Sirm Catcher?
The left one.
Yeah.
This Harvester?
I mean, there's no one contesting us for it.
Let's drop right now.
Yeah.
I'm right behind you.
I'm gonna go down.
Drop right here and then... One sec.
One sec.
Harvester.
Go ahead.
I'm ready.
I'll jump down the other one.
Yay.
Oh my god.
Not scared at all.
So scary.
Yeah.
We just land on a full team.
So sketch.
They're just looking at us.
Fucking ratting.
Oh.
We're not in 19th place as well.
Hey.
We're fucking improving.
Let's go.
We're surviving.
Yeah.
We're getting better and better.
Oh.
There's a drop here too.
I'm gonna go for the Harvester.
You guys can go for the drop.
Okay.
The crow went this way.
What?
Should I get the golden repeater?
Yeah.
Do it.
I'll go with Tayo.
Just in case we get...
Ape done.
Yeah.
I'll look behind.
Is my crow going backwards?
We're just gonna go down in this... the cannon.
I have a lot of attachments for my hemlock.
If you guys want.
Like purple.
You have a 3x on it?
Yeah.
2x4.
Wait.
What's this?
The cache?
Oh.
It makes you purple.
I think you should have it.
Yeah.
You should have it.
The pro should have this.
Not me.
Wait.
Did you take it?
No.
Okay.
I thought you did.
Because you went purple.
I was like wait.
What the fuck?
Be careful of a team coming here.
Yeah.
There was a team that scanned us.
Are you gonna come?
Yeah.
I'm just guarding this shit.
I'll scan behind the drone.
Yeah.
Just make sure no team walks up on us.
Just in case.
Yeah.
Make sure...
Cause we're not getting mirrored by that team.
Looks clear.
I want them to go on the other side.
Where's this chick?
Where do we go next?
Alright.
We're just playing this cannon area.
Yeah.
There's most likely a team that...
I can't really do in-fighting.
Oh, Ty.
Come here.
Yeah.
I'm coming.
Looking right now.
I have a repeater and a peacekeeper.
So...
Not too great.
Scan this right side.
I'm gonna look left.
I'll hug this wall and scan.
If no one's on right, take space on the right.
And I'm just taking...
I think he's on the left as well.
I didn't seem to scan anybody.
Alright.
I'm in.
I'm in zone here too.
I'm watching our back too.
Yeah.
I'm gonna look.
If there's a team behind us, just posture up to fight.
Yeah.
You're on repeater.
You should be able to.
Do you think we can get that Evo or nah?
Guys.
We can.
I got 84 damage.
Oh my god.
Improvement.
Nice.
Just someone watch behind us.
Yeah.
I'm watching.
Someone walks up.
Yeah.
I'm watching behind for us.
Ty.
You can look behind.
I can look behind.
Oh shit.
You're not in a bad spot.
On that height here.
We have re-deployers?
We have a re-deploy.
Yeah.
Where the fuck did that team go behind us?
They're moving.
They ran to the other side.
Where are they going?
There's a team there though.
There's a team playing this like house.
Where are we in?
We're in right here.
On that rock.
Oh you're purple.
Hold on.
Keep watching our back.
I'm gonna scout in front.
To see like where we can play.
Yeah.
I don't think there's anybody in zone at all.
I'm looking at the right side just in case.
The people in front of us were a Watton squad.
So if you see the same.
Oh yeah.
It's a Watson Newcastle over there.
Just fucking killing in the cross.
I'm a foreigner.
There's no one to our right at the moment.
We have a spot.
Okay.
We have like...
decent spot to play.
I'm heading over here.
Let me just confirm it.
Oh they're about to fight.
I'm looking at our backs just in case.
Wait.
Okay.
We're gonna chill right here.
On this zone.
Wait.
Can I move from the left?
We're ratting right here.
Yeah.
You should.
We don't want to give presence.
There's a team here.
Like the team playing the building probably.
And this is the Watson team playing in the corner.
They saw us.
Come to my side.
It's fine.
We have cover here.
Lots of fucking cover.
This team can't walk up.
Like this team can't walk up.
Because they're just gonna get shot by this team.
I'm looking at this team right now.
Since they saw us already anyways.
Stay there.
Stay there on the height.
I'll look at the left side first.
Keep watching this team on the left.
Yeah.
I'm looking left.
I'm gonna make sure they don't fucking...
fucking...
rap us here.
Let me shoot.
Whoa.
Okay.
I heal.
Whoa.
Is there...
Can you like move up on the left side somehow?
Is there like a cover?
We get zoned.
No.
I don't think so.
The cover's not gonna best.
I'm gonna stay to the right.
Oh.
They're rocketing us.
No.
There's no cover.
I was looking.
Yeah.
There's no cover.
Let me just play here.
Alright.
We can fly too.
Yeah.
We have to read the play as well.
Ouch.
How many bats do you guys have?
I have... This team's getting shot on the right.
I have two.
They're getting pushed.
This Watson team's getting pushed right now.
Okay.
I need a bat.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna scan in front of me just in case.
Alright.
Yeah.
I think... Yeah.
I'm five cells one bat.
I'm gaming.
I have ten damage.
Are they still... Is the Watson team still there on the right?
Yeah.
Looks like it.
There's a team right here I'm ping.
I see it.
This one's hard.
I ain't even finna lie.
I mean we could read the play.
I have no way.
Back here.
Yeah.
We could like...
We could like valk from where I am and like look around.
Or valk them.
Wait.
They just rest.
What the fuck?
There's a team right here I'm ping.
I don't know if that's the same team but...
That like got a better angle.
Yeah.
Come on.
I'm watching.
But they're definitely not from there.
I'm swinging right to...
Yeah.
There's a team.
That's a different team over there then.
Why aren't they shooting each other?
The fuck?
No.
They're teaming.
They're teaming bro.
I'm moving up to the tree.
Buds!
Did they leave?
They left.
They came to the left.
We can flank this team I think.
Alright.
I'm coming to you.
Should we rotate to your east?
Oh no.
They're still there.
Nah.
We have 14 seconds.
I think we have to fly.
Alright.
This is the best cover I think.
Right?
Oh no.
There's people.
We just fly.
Come to my side.
And we fly right here.
Right here?
I'm flying?
Yeah.
I'm here.
Alright.
There we go.
We got ping for injuries.
Just look around.
We have a tree.
We have like little trees here.
Fly like towards here on the left.
Ummm.
Keep flying.
The house is taken?
Land.
Land on the second floor.
We're gonna fight the second floor.
I'm gonna go in the door.
No one's here.
That's our house.
Our new house.
Come to the second floor.
Yes.
Okay.
This door is open.
Yes.
It's fine.
We have a house.
We still have a door here.
I'm chilling on this door.
Yeah.
Wait.
Somebody's knocked.
You see that?
Wait.
Someone's knocked.
I'm gonna peek alone.
Okay.
Here is.
Don't let your East die.
Protect your East.
Okay.
We're just chill.
Don't do too much.
If we hear them resing.
We peek but don't commit to the first floor.
I can scan in two.
I'll scan again.
Oh.
We have zone.
No.
They res.
She's still knocked right there.
Wait.
What?
No.
I'm pretty sure there's three.
There was four.
I scanned four people.
Okay.
That's different team knocked then.
Yeah.
I'll scan again in four.
Makes sense.
I'll scan in four.
We're in zone.
Yeah.
See.
You see that?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that guy?
Me.
On the guy in the back.
I'm looking.
Just make sure we're not getting climbed up on.
I cracked too.
Yeah.
Oh.
I think they killed him.
Yeah.
I'm trying it.
They got him.
Wait.
What?
Oh.
They're above us.
They're above.
What is that corner?
That is an insane corner.
I think they're gonna drop.
If this team drops, we play behind right here.
Okay?
Okay.
And we're gonna watch a fucking angle.
They're peeking us.
They can't get in.
Throw your like thermites in these as well.
I knocked one.
Nice.
I kept hacking Newcastle res.
Uh.
There's people up top there too.
Watch out for that angle.
They're all up top.
There's no one below us.
I'm gonna bang ult on this zone close.
Look at this tire.
You hit this tire.
Left.
West.
I'm looking at right.
I don't see anything.
I'm bang ulting now.
Wait.
There's a team below us now.
I can scan in.
I'm bang ulting.
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's a huge fight to our left.
Huge fight to our left.
I smoked our right.
I hit someone for flash.
I didn't take anyone.
I hit someone on the right.
I'm gonna look height.
Before they drop.
I'm looking up right here maybe.
They might drop.
Scanning?
It's just one team below us.
Just one team.
No one's on height, huh?
Yeah.
I didn't scan anybody.
I'm not sure if my scan didn't pick it up or anything.
Does anyone have a bat?
Yeah.
I'm looking at these guys right now.
I have a nice scan here.
Yeah.
It's just one team below us.
Six hostiles?
Who the fuck are they?
There's still a team on height.
Yeah.
They're all the way up there.
I was like, where the fuck did I get six?
I don't have a lot of ammo.
Do you guys have extra light or no?
No light.
Okay.
I'm gonna run 12 now then.
I think you can play on the height with me.
One of you.
I think Taya should play height then.
We have like a little roof here, Taya.
Yeah.
I'm watching height.
Just make sure.
Just so we don't get climbed up on.
Watch these little...
Look at this.
There's the evac.
Look at the evac.
Scanning.
There you go.
There's a team up.
Jumping down.
I'm covering.
I'm dropping.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
I saw that guy run up to you.
Holy shit.
I'm watching this.
I'm watching this team.
We have to get out of this.
They're running out.
Running out.
There's a team on a roof.
On a roof?
Yeah.
I'm fucking scanning.
I'm gonna ult this.
A full team on a roof.
We have to leave soon because of zone.
Oh that's you.
I knocked one on height.
I'm killing.
I can scan in two.
I'm on height with you.
I got one.
Yeah.
Full.
Full dead.
Nice.
I'm looking down.
Here.
There's people to our left.
People to our left too.
I'm looking.
Oh that Bangalore is one.
Nice.
Wait.
Left.
Look left.
Wait.
We gotta go down to the second floor.
Second floor.
I can't go down.
I'm batting.
I'm bombing a med kit.
I'm gonna fly.
I'm gonna.
Wait.
Should I fly?
We got an ape left.
An ape left.
Ape left.
I'm gonna land on their heads.
Okay?
Oh I got some.
I got some.
I'm batting.
I'm shooting and killing.
I'm gonna land on their heads.
Alright.
Pop a bat.
Ready?
Gaping.
Going in?
No...
TAYO LIVE!
TAYO!
NOOOO!
Fucking Newcastle bro.
The Newcastle!
We grieved the Newcastle team.
We got third though!
We got third!
Bro that is insane!
You see this guys?
Look at us!
All odds against us.
Oh it's them again.
Bro just give them the money!
Just give them the money bro!
We need like...
Just like a beer.
Like we're done.
Let them sit out next game.
They already won.
There's no one fucking catching up.
That is insane.
That was actually a fun round.
Bro that was crazy.
Look at us.
Bro they have 17 kills!
Dude they killed everybody for us.
For us!
Wait...
I can't see my damage.
Fuck.
I thought I did a lot.
You did a thousand.
I saw it.
Don't worry.
I got you.
A thousand!
Thank you!
Apex gods!
That's a god.
Oh my god!
17 kills!
Bro we like knocked so many people but they kept getting res.
Yo what the fuck was that man?
We got robbed.
We got robbed of our kills.
Mods!
Mods come on!
Give us those points!
What's going on here?
Hello?
Yeah.
Scammed.
Nox should count us points.
Yeah.
Please Apex.
Please.
It should count.
That shit should count.
Oh is this the last round?
Yeah last game.
Round 6.
This is fun though.
Bro we could have played so high if I didn't get blue screened.
I actually feel like I got a good position too.
Yeah.
Yeah and I trust both of them.
We both play over so I trust both of our FPS skills.
Oh my god.
That was actually fun.
Yeah that was a good game.
World's Edge last game.
Same place.
Yup yup.
Apparently someone said they killed 7 teams.
I don't know.
Jesus.
7 teams?
Bro this guy killed 17.
Dude he's just a terminator.
You just never want to see him.
Bro put him on P20.
P20 nerf right now.
Yeah you should only be allowed to.
Yeah.
You should only.
You should get the P20 nerf.
No attachments.
He's probably better than me.
With the P20.
Yeah you have your fucking match.
With your PK.
And he still gets like 20 headshots.
Yeah.
Bro.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared to fight.
Fight team 20.
It might be team 20.
It's like you never know.
I want to know what the point gap is.
I'm actually so curious.
I think there's a limit to kill points.
Yeah but they got like.
They got 3 first places in the ranked.
3 first places.
That's true.
He didn't win the solo right?
Who won the solo?
Not you Cav no.
It was...
Oh Lyca.
Oh yeah.
Alright chat tell us.
Tell us like the first place team points.
And then the second place team points.
I'm actually so curious.
I'm so curious.
How far ahead they are.
That's insane.
That's such a strong lineup.
Alright.
We peaked.
You know it's because of that lockdown we did.
Yeah.
Yeah we were warmed up.
That's actually true.
We should have played lockdown in the beginning.
We should have done that.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We could have been like thirds all the time.
Okay.
The next match will not have kill point limit.
Oh he's gonna fucking go wild.
Yeah he's gonna get like 21 on his own.
Yeah.
They drop off with solos.
All three go solos.
Yeah they're just different places.
Yeah.
They all go to different LAN sites.
POS.
Here we go.
How much is the...
Yeah.
Beacons now let you know where the enemy is instead of the next ring?
No no there's two.
There's two.
There's a ring console.
There's the ring and then there's the beacon.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's like map room scan and ring scan.
We just don't have the character for map room.
Or not map room.
We don't have the character for ring.
So we just rely.
But we know where everyone else is going.
Yeah.
So it's pretty much the same thing.
I like how some of my chat is like team 20 is first, second and third.
Yeah.
Holy!
First is 63 points.
Second is 47.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
That's a... the gap is not as bad as I thought.
We're second right?
Yeah we're top 10.
No.
We're 10th place.
Actually?
Yeah we're actually top 10.
Oh god.
Yeah we're top 10.
Bro!
Hello?
Our goal...
Not last.
Bro wait.
This last game is...
The last game makes or breaks it though.
Yeah we gotta get some KP.
I feel like everyone just plays normally.
Our landmark is really bad for KP.
Yeah we just get shit.
I think we just play normally.
No?
Yeah we just play... I think we just play how we normally play.
Our fucking beaconsy has been... been working well.
Let me in!
I wanna play!
Oh there we go.
Let us in!
We just won a game.
Oh!
We're starting.
Yes!
Same team comp.
Wait where are we landing again?
Um...
Oh yeah middle.
The place.
That place.
Oh I get Mirage.
I get Mirage.
You guys go land that area.
Yeah ping me a Carbine and a Volt.
Carbine, Volt.
Yeah.
Carbine, Volt has been working well for me.
Or a Repeater.
Carbine, Volt.
Carbine, Repeater, Volt.
Let's go!
Alright.
Here we go.
Yeah shit.
Sick.
Alright.
Oh I'm gonna land Mirage now since the beacon is...
Oh there's no beacon right?
Yeah.
Yeah okay.
I shall go.
Alright.
I'll land with Tayo then.
Let's go.
I know this map.
I trust in our IGLs.
I got you guys.
I land the top.
You can get the bottom, Tayo.
I'll grab the top.
You start!
Bro I felt like we knocked like a billion people last game bro.
Yeah.
Everyone just got rezzed.
Bro I'm alive.
I was like oh my god we're farming.
Yeah I was like oh my god we got so many kills.
Nope.
It was like two.
Two.
Okay.
Let's see.
I think I'll go Repeater.
Actually I'll run Carbine.
I have a Bolt for you.
Alright.
I found Bolt just now too.
You can have it if you want that.
I'm good.
Wait we might have zone guys.
Oh.
Okay that's not good.
We have to just loot fast and just set up I guess.
Wait yeah.
That is actually not good.
We're gonna get fucking...
I have the key thing too.
If we need.
And blue backpack.
Let me know when to scan.
Shit.
Cause I feel like...
I don't know.
I don't know if I should scan early.
But like I'm worried that I'm gonna get fucking run up on.
When we are about to leave probably.
Scan.
Ooh.
First kill.
Revenant.
This is running in.
I got the ulti stuff.
Rev.
Oh god.
It started.
Oh people are going for kills.
Wait can I loot this?
Yeah.
Very cool.
I'm gonna grab that blue backpack then.
Alright I'm gonna grab the...
Our little...
The lava fissure team is ballooning right now.
They have a B.
Are they ballooning to us?
Let's see where they are going.
I don't see where they are going yet.
They are heading towards...
Probably thermal choke.
Yeah they are heading towards...
If they are heading towards thermal go up this choke.
Or that height right here.
You want me to scan or no?
Wait there is no balloon.
There is no balloon.
Yeah yeah yeah scan the beacon.
Wait wait there is a shield.
I think there is a shield here.
They are on me.
Wait I'm coming.
They are over here.
They haven't crossed yet.
I think they are just rotating.
Okay.
I'll get a splurge.
I'm coming to you guys.
They are just going towards thermal.
We can go for the beacon scan.
I'll watch.
They left.
Attack 140.
That was scary.
Holy shit.
Where are we going?
I'm going to scan first.
Top of the hill.
Let's see.
Wait scan this...
What is this drop?
Yeah everyone is going to thermal.
Wait I think we should... let's go for this drop.
Let's go for this drop.
I have the key on me.
I need a scope.
If you guys found one.
Go play for this drop.
I'm going to get our weapon supply.
Okay.
I'm waiting for the drop right now.
I'm not risking that Ashe.
I feel like somebody...
I feel like they are going to grab it first before us.
We are good.
We are chilling.
There is thermal.
They are resing.
They are resing at...
Whatever it's called.
Volcano shit.
Whatever that English...
Lava Fisher.
Volcano shit.
What is it?
Oh gold.
Not bad.
Are we just going to get it?
It's not bad.
Do you want to use it?
I can't.
I'll drop my bolt.
Anyone wants to have a purple?
Nah I'm just going to shotgun.
Alright I'm going to run double light.
Let's go.
We hold here and we always...
We just hold our mirage side.
Alright.
Oh finally a scope.
Okay this is going to be the most...
I'm going to drop the key.
Because I don't think we are going to grab it anyway.
We need to...
We only need to fight once here.
Once or twice.
Once we win those one...
Those once or two fights...
We have a...
Okay I'll look in front of us then while you guys...
I just...
I'm just looking behind.
I'll look in the front then.
There's a Watson team in the house.
There's a medkit here.
That's probably Cheeki and them again bro.
No.
They're farming everybody.
They're just running it down.
Yeah too bad it's the 20th team.
There's a team...
There's a Loba team in this house.
And so...
There's a Loba lifeline team.
They just don't care about the KP.
Yeah they...
Oh they're placement man.
Oh they're like lifeline drop.
Alright.
You gotta let me know who's cracked.
Because I have my pew pew pew.
My hammer point.
I'm just smoking out.
Try to make my presence known.
Please.
Okay.
I don't know the fucking drop off.
But it's fine.
That was a single fire.
God damn it.
Is that Rampart too?
I single fired that shit.
Yeah it's Rampart.
Wait no it's Rampart Caustic Loba.
Yeah.
I was like wait a minute.
That's a Rampart.
I don't wanna waste my life.
You guys on board.
No don't do anything.
Taya we gotta keep top 10.
No.
Turn off your DPS brain.
We got an honorable ending here.
Okay you're serious.
There should be a party there by the way.
They're rezzing at lava fission.
Yeah.
And before it's like fucking harvest area.
Oh yes we got zone.
Nice.
Yes.
I shouldn't push up past this.
Yeah nah.
Oh people.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna scan for you.
They're like really far off.
Yeah look behind here.
They're far.
They're probably gonna just chill there until like next zone.
They might ape.
Watch out.
I'm looking.
I'm looking across for you.
I'm watching.
I don't think anybody's gonna.
They're gonna wait there until next zone.
For sure.
You guys need this?
Someone's being a little.
Oh that's a valve.
Let's see.
They fucked up?
No.
Blue purples.
They're over there.
I'm gonna get angles here.
I'm gonna look behind still.
We need to look behind still.
They're on top of the roof.
Let me push here then.
I'm looking behind us.
They're below you.
They're like on this rock.
They're not getting shot from behind.
No last.
Woah woah woah.
I got sniped by.
People behind?
No no no.
Here here.
I got sniped from behind us.
I only have two shield cells left.
They're like right there.
I have a bunch of shield cells.
I'll give you.
I have three bats though.
Do you need bats?
Yeah I need one bat please.
One bat to bat.
Shoot them.
Yes.
Why are you shooting us?
Am I?
Oh my god.
I'll look.
I'll still look behind us.
I'll stay here then.
So I won't get shot.
The team that's.
That fucking.
Team is not shooting them.
Yeah they're in the house.
Why aren't they shooting them?
They're scared.
Yeah.
They need the placements.
I'm about to shoot at the house.
Get their attention.
Yeah look at.
Look over here.
The fuck?
I swear if you shoot them.
And they look at me.
I swear to god.
I'm gonna shoot them.
That should do it right?
Oh you're using some brain stress here.
I don't see anybody yet.
I don't have any fucking ammo.
Yeah looks like it.
Right there.
Oh team team team team.
They landed to our left.
Okay okay.
I see that.
They're on the height right now.
Here on the rock.
They smoked?
They're smoking us.
I didn't get anybody my scan.
I'm watching.
Not pushing it.
If we fight this.
We can't get knocked since we're just gonna get pushed by this team as well.
Yeah.
We kinda have to fight from like a little more up front.
So we don't get.
Looks like they're rotating.
They're getting shot from other people.
I can scan the three.
Oh they're on top of the thing.
They dropped.
There's two teams there.
That should be good.
They start fighting.
Someone needs to watch that.
They're playing the bus right now.
I'm still watching for us.
I see him.
He's like.
They ran to our left.
He's behind that rock.
I'm watching them.
They slid down again.
It's a Pathfinder Bang team.
They're still there.
Oh.
Okay I'm batting.
I expected this.
35 purple.
Cracked a bang.
I'm going to go to the people under here.
Only one bat so I'm not going to poke too much.
How many cells do you have?
I have a lot of cells.
This team shouldn't go for us.
They should just stay on their side.
This team.
We're going to play for a Valkyld here.
A good Valkyld is probably going to be landing underneath here.
That platform.
Okay.
Where should we Valkyld?
We can just look.
We can just Valkyld from over here.
Looks like they're pushing us.
Oh.
Scatting?
I'm watching.
Don't give them entry.
I'm just going to ult for now.
I can give you ult.
I have ult.
I don't think they're going to push.
I think they're also just making sure we don't push them.
Maybe.
Or maybe the Bloodhound ult scared them.
They came up to the...
They ran back.
Where the fuck?
Wait for Valkyld.
We're going to Valkyld from here.
Over here?
I think that's the Bloodhound.
The Bloodhound ult definitely scared them.
Yeah, I got one.
It's fine.
I have one as well.
I'll just do it again so we can have it for...
Yeah, the next fight.
17 seconds.
Come to my side.
Yes sir.
We're just going to Valkyld from here as well.
Here?
Right here is fine?
Is it...
Do we have cover here?
Yeah, I'm just worried about...
Here?
Can we do it?
Team shouldn't push us.
3, 2, 1.
Rip it.
I'm just going to spam sping where we're landing.
Just move towards like over here.
No one's underneath.
Let's go.
Take underneath.
Underneath the platform.
Okay.
I'm on it.
Just chill right here.
Alright, we're just chilling right here.
Alright.
Watch our landings as well.
Do I scan?
And make presence now?
Just show presence.
I got one.
Yeah, on top of the building.
There's a caustic.
How many how many do you have?
How many teams is that?
116.
There's so many teams by the way.
Oh ho.
Okay, I got one kill.
I'm going to look forward.
Keep watching our back.
Yeah, I'm watching up here.
I'm watching up here.
I'm going to get shot though from here.
No, actually I should be fine.
There's a team right here.
Scanning?
That's the team that I killed.
I think the people in the house.
Ummm.
I popped my ult.
Popped this ult itself.
Hiya.
Right here.
I'm 40 right now.
I got my gold helmet too.
Might need to vapple for this.
Like a squad here.
Since there's a team in front of us.
Blue armor in the house.
Can't really fight this drop really.
83.
Just going to get shot in the back.
Oh wait, they rez'd.
Okay.
90.
We're going to play for this like...
Just walk it in.
Walk it in.
Make sure this team behind us, like, don't push us.
I'm looking at them.
They've been in the house so far.
They've just been in this house.
There's people on the first floor.
Right here.
I vault.
I'll get back your helmet.
There's like a team.
There's a team.
Not Ferdinand and Choke from there.
The Choke team.
Yeah.
Tell me when to fight.
Fighting on the height.
They're just fighting here on the height.
Watching this team.
This team might drop into us maybe.
Holy what the fuck.
Woah!
What's going on?
Oh no.
Holy shit.
Yeah this team is watching us now.
This team is looking.
This team might drop down.
We're back out now?
Back out right now.
We're going to look for like a third party or...
Yeah we're going to look for a third party.
Just fly around.
Fly around.
Just fly in a circle maybe?
Just like fly around.
Yeah.
Fly in circles.
Ding.
Jesus Christ.
Land right here.
On the height.
I didn't fucking make it.
I'm ulting the same.
I make it to the height too.
The Bloodhound.
Pushing left.
I'm scanning.
I'm hugging this wall.
Push this Bloodhound.
I'm ulting.
I got hit by that.
Fuck.
Okay.
Crack crack crack crack.
Wait I don't have a bat.
I'm selling.
What the please.
What is this?
Which one?
Right there.
In front of you.
I got one.
Oh I didn't see that guy.
Oh no.
No man.
13th.
Bro how many people were there?
There's too many people.
I dead slid.
Bro.
I thought they were getting shot in the back.
Of course it's fucking Cheeki and them.
Wait.
Where is the Bloodhound?
Cheeki.
Is Cheeki the Bloodhound?
No.
I literally clipped him with my finger ma-jig.
The half.
The headlock.
He was like probably like half meat.
And then he just turned around and just one mag me.
I'll fully see.
Bro of course.
Of course we landed on Cheeki man.
I dead slid like.
We could have landed on anybody.
It had to be Cheeki.
Yeah it had to be.
I thought they were getting shot in the back.
Like when we were like flying they looked like they were getting shot in the back.
And I almost killed their bang too.
I think they just finished their fight when we landed maybe.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Or like the team didn't like push them.
Oh my god of all people.
There was like 17 teams there.
Yeah.
We picked the bad one.
We picked the fucking.
The first place team.
The worst possible.
Our gotcha luck is terrible guys.
I'm just gonna watch Cheeki shit on these kids.
What the fuck.
Bro I'm just gonna watch.
Yeah I'm gonna watch.
Hello.
What is he has no recoil.
He has no recoil.
Bro it's Cheeki man.
He actually has no recoil.
Bro rank hardened him so hard.
Dude he's literally getting ammo like.
He's getting fed.
And he's like oh what the fuck.
Bro what the.
What's the difference of this.
He's so good.
What's the difference.
Bro of course he's on Bloodhound.
The roller player is always on Bloodhound.
Bro.
Bro there's no.
I can't compare to that.
This dude literally just.
180s and just headshots me five times in a row.
What am I supposed to do.
Nothing.
You just roll over and die.
You show your stomach.
And you're like.
Dude he's running out.
Dude he's an ape.
What an ape.
Is he gonna win?
Bro is he gonna win again?
No way.
They winning again.
Oh my god.
That fucking gipy bubble saved their life.
Holy fuck.
He can't miss.
No.
He won't miss.
What?
That's not fair.
No.
I wish Valk ult.
They tell you which team you're landing on.
If I knew it was cheeky.
I would not have landed there.
I would fucking left.
It's not fair man.
Fourth first place is in a row.
Bro.
They've won every single one right?
They won every single trio.
Every trio they've won.
Bro check his controller.
Yeah dude.
His controller is like taking some.
Bro what controller does he use?
Let me buy it.
What place for me?
13th with one kill.
That's not bad.
We got points.
Fucking 13 kills.
We died with the team that won.
Yeah.
That doesn't count.
We're like second place.
It doesn't count.
We landed on them.
We were the only team to contest them.
We were the only team that stood up and were like no.
We are going to 1v1 you guys.
Come at us.
I'm pretty sure the other team is just fucking also trying to kill them and die.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That team was insane.
Holy shit.
Bro check his computer man.
That was fun though.
I had a great time with you guys.
I had an amazing time.
Bro we should play Overwatch together.
You should.
Taya should carry him.
It's Taya's turn to carry him.
Yeah wait.
You should be in Overwatch now.
Yeah Taya next time.
You guys gotta carry.
Get your revenge.
Get your revenge on fucking Taya.
Yeah.
Help your reese get to Diamond.
Can we get Cheeki in here?
Get Cheeki into the team.
Yeah get him.
1v1 Taya.
In Overwatch.
There is no aim assist there.
But he is like immortal 3 in Valorant 2.
Bro he is immortal 3?
Yeah he is actually good in Valorant as well.
Bro wait.
He might win the 1v1 Taya.
He might be better than you in Overwatch.
Probably not.
I think I'm fine.
Don't worry about that.
GG's.
Let's see what placement we got.
Oh yeah.
Isn't there like a mainstream?
Yeah there should be.
Where is the Skars mainstream?
Skars Cup.
I think they are doing an interview right now.
With Cheeki?
Yeah Cheeki.
The immortal god.
The 4 first places.
I'm pretty sure he is the god of Apex.
If anyone.
No no that's...
I mean maybe he is the CEO in Japan.
The CEO in Japan.
The CEO.
Yeah exactly.
We have Hal and NN.
Apparently there is like a random hat winner.
Oh yeah yeah.
They pull like a piece of paper to see who gets it.
And then...
Yeah yeah yeah.
So like we could...
Maybe you know we don't have luck here.
But we have luck in the gacha.
That is true.
It's all about the gacha.
I'm getting off though once we get our leaderboard.
I'm sick right now.
Oh shit.
From yesterday.
I didn't sleep until like 6am.
Bro what you came in here with no sleep?
This man was out partying.
That's where it gets us in the beginning.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
You know we got 3rd place even with all the debuffs.
In that last game.
With all that debuffs we still got 3rd in that last game.
That's all that matters.
Oh they are still watching.
Yeah.
This dude just kills 3 people.
He just kills 4 people in a row.
You know.
This is a normal Tuesday.
Just normal cheeky days.
That's like a little ranked game.
Yeah this man plays ranked even when there's hackers every day.
Yeah cause he's stronger than them.
He's stronger than the hackers.
He's just better.
At least we know we're not last.
That's all that matters.
Not last.
Let's go.
Not last equals win.
Placements don't matter.
It's only first and last place.
And we weren't last.
Technically we can be second.
What is...
We're in 14th place.
Almost.
Not last.
That's all.
We're better than...
Look at all these other people we're better than.
It's alright.
Nice.
We're not that far from top...
Top 5.
Top 5 yeah.
If we got the kill points from that other game.
I think we would be like 8 or 9.
Yeah.
If we didn't land on cheeky's team we could have been top 10.
We could have been top 10.
It could have been.
There's like 3 people that have 24 points.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
Hey you got your estimate right.
You were like 14th to 15th place.
You got it right.
You read us perfectly.
What can I say man.
We did it guys.
Thank you guys.
That was... I enjoyed that a lot.
Yeah me too.
GG's.
Next time.
Next time Tayo carries us in Overwatch.
Next time it's Overwatch we might carry you guys.
Yeah yeah.
Boost your ease to...
Wait wait wait.
Whoa whoa boost.
Mercy pocket with Mercy.
Damage boost.
That's what I'm saying.
As Mercy.
You have your supports like gold right?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Yeah you just play Mercy and damage boost your ease.
Yeah boost him.
Yeah.
Damage boost.
For legal reasons I meant damage boost.
Not anything else.
I don't even know anything else but damage boost.
Yeah exactly.
You don't need heals.
A true Mercy player knows it's all about damage boosting.
Yeah.
He doesn't need heals if he kills everybody.
He has... yeah they have regen now.
Overwatch players can eat regen.
Yeah like you don't even need heals.
Yeah you don't even...
Wait was that not a thing before?
No yeah no it was only...
Wait really?
There was only support players.
Yeah and then they added support and then they're like everybody gets regen.
What?
Oh shit.
Yeah so don't worry.
You don't need heals.
You just wait for your regen.
Alright.
GG's guys.
That was fun.
You guys get some rest.
Yeah.
Get some rest.
Your ease can feel better.
Thank you.
Nice meeting both of you guys.
GG's.
Bye bye.
I had a great time.
That was my first time like interacting with your ease and Taya in game.
That was so fun.
We were so close to top 10.
We were literally...
Literally top 10 was 3 points away.
It was so crazy.
Everyone was so fucking congested together.
If I didn't get the blue screen.
It was the blue screen.
I still can't believe I got the blue screen.
That's so fucked up.
Also Tommy I want to say thank you for the Also Tommy I want to say thank you for the super chats.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to read it.
I couldn't read super chats while streaming.
But thank you again Tommy.
Not when I'm streaming.
When I'm doing collab.
Sometimes I'm not able to read super chats.
But thank you so much.
6.30 am on Friday.
We're feeling generous.
Enjoy your beans.
Get some good food.
Thank you again for the aca aca sopa.
I can't believe it.
We were so close.
We could have actually got top 10 if I didn't blue screen.
The curse.
I got cursed by Tayo.
I actually got cursed by Tayo.
It's like crazy man.
But yeah anyway.
It was incredibly fun.
Playing with them.
I had a great time.
That was my first JP tournament back here.
As Doki.
I'm really happy that they invited me.
And I'm really happy that it was fun just messing around.
Just talking.
Oh my god.
Challenger circuit is tomorrow.
By the way.
We have not fucking practiced.
At all.
As a team.
Because everybody's busy.
I gave them my schedule too.
I was like.
Here's my schedule.
As long as I can do it before my streams.
That's really good.
And then we're supposed to practice today.
Like today.
On my rest day.
Or like on my rest day.
And then the thing is.
The thing was.
We don't know what happened to Wig.
He disappeared.
He actually.
We don't know what happened to him.
He like never showed up.
We're like.
Where's Wig?
Are you ready?
I just woke up.
I'm ready to play.
Where's Wig?
And then he never.
We don't know what happened to him.
And then we had like somebody.
Like text him.
Cause they had their phone number.
So they're like.
Hey where are you?
And he never responded.
And then like.
Yeah he had like 3 hours of sleep.
So I think he's fucking out.
And I'm like.
What?
I was like.
Bro.
Cause at first.
We were supposed to play.
The day before.
The day before yesterday.
But then Wig was like.
I can't make it.
Can we do that?
Can we do like Thursday?
And I was like.
Yeah sure we can do Thursday.
Then he never showed up.
Bro.
What happened?
Guys.
I don't know.
I think we're out in round 1.
Which I'm fine with.
Honestly.
It's alright.
If we're out after.
Honestly.
I'm totally fine.
If we're out after round 1.
I tried.
I won.
I woke up.
Like.
I actually woke up.
Guys.
So.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
But like.
We'll see.
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you everybody for coming to the stream.
I hope you guys all had amazing fun times.
With Yuris and Tayo.
I'm totally down to play Overwatch with them.
It'll be really fun.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Get in the mood to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cuz you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.